new reporting by the intercept
shows that
anthony fauci lied and i think we knew
that because there was a there was a
study that came out 2017 dr rand paul
actually held i i think he or he quoted
it when he was questioning fauci
and in this scientific study they say
they received funding from the nih and
ecohealth alliance and that in this
study they actually made chimeric
viruses which is basically gain of
function but dr fauci pushed back saying
up and down the chain it was determined
this was not gain of function research
well as much as most people believe that
he would wash and say most but a lot of
people believe that he was lying we now
this report from the intercept which
also published 900 pages and we now have
a professor from rutgers saying outright
this shows they were doing what is
defined by the federal government as
gain of function research there there's
the grant application there's the
progress reports this was
gain of function research
and dr anthony fauci lied or i should
say to quote the professor he was being
untruthful well i'll be a little bit
more bold than that now rand paul is
saying see told you he lied he lied
again now rand paul has called for
criminal action in the past i really
don't think anything is going to happen
so we'll talk about this we got a bunch
of other news
i've talked about a lot of this stuff
earlier today but we're going to break
break it all down get into the
conversation around it we have that
rachel maddow story you may have seen
rachel maddow tweeted fake news about
ivermectin and oklahoma hospitals being
overrun didn't happen but apparently
she's still pushing the story i guess
and people are criticizing her so we'll
get in all that as well as potentially
some afghanistan stuff and we are being
joined by journalist zed jalani how's it
going man oh it's great it's good to be
here do you want to just give a quick
introduction to who you are yeah so i am
uh
right now i'm a freelance journalist i
keep a sub stack with my friend shot
miss roby on inquiremoor.com
uh but i've spent probably a dozen years
in journalism i was a staff reporter at
the intercept
i was a reporter for alternet i was a
reporter back at thinkprogress back when
it still existed at center for american
progress and i contribute to a range of
publications the washington examiner
tablet magazine um
basically uh if you read it i probably
have probably written something at some
point there written in the atlantic
recently did a mini documentary for fox
news over over the summer so yeah i in a
way i'm prolific i guess but i just kind
of uh
you know i want to go out there and
explain the world i want to figure
things out together so right on that's
interesting that you worked for think
progress alternate the intercept all
particularly left or establishment
publications and then you're like i also
did something for fox news over the
summer you know i think back in the day
you could and it wasn't really that big
of a deal but in this in this past
decade it's been getting worse and worse
to where it's like you're on one side or
the other but i do think it's
interesting that you having worked at
those places i'm sure many of our
viewers are not fans of but glenn
greenwald is you know citing you on
twitter saying you're a journalist
rachel maddow's a crackpot and i think
you know that speaks that says a lot so
it'll be interesting to talk about this
reporting from the intercept uh and the
history of these organizations i think
or at least the recent history and we'll
get into like this shift in in culture
you know uh we have another story from
the aclu
the aclu what only a couple years ago
was it they were saying
vaccine passports are bad and wrong we
can't do it
yeah they had put out a report i think
it was in 2008 or 2009 basically saying
that in pandemics government shouldn't
be violating civil liberties right they
need to focus on education on public
health they don't need to focus on
criminalization or you know measures
that we would at that time anyway
consider authoritarian but yeah they've
done a total about face um basically in
the past year where they've embraced
both uh mass mandates and schools and
also vaccine mandates and other contexts
one of the articles that i think uh
glenn posted is from 2020 where they
were like pax passports are not the
answer now they have an op-ed in the new
york times saying yes passports are good
and not a violation of civil liberties
these organizations have lost the plot
but i really want to talk about a lot of
that stuff we'll start with the news we
also got ian oh yeah ian crossland
what's up everybody
happy to be here good to see you too
after the long weekend that's right long
weekend we got uh lydia hanging out yeah
i'm also in the corner very excited to
be here as well i'm excited to talk
about the polarization how all this has
shifted
strangely to the left and i would say
that we could probably just follow all
the money to see what's really going on
and before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member support our
fierce and independent journalism we got
a bunch of great reporters we're hiring
more by the day well that's not not true
we're hiring as many as we can as fast
as we can but it's not easy to vet
people and make sure that you know
they're going to do good work but um we
are actually in the process of
formalizing our non-profit as well which
is going to do fact checking
for us and many other organizations and
we're also going to issue ratings
it's it's a big thing but generally you
know uh
if you're a member you will support our
journalism you'll get access to
members-only segments but we're also
going to be launching a fact-checking
outlet that's going to provide ratings
to other news outlets based on a random
sampling of recent articles they publish
and whether or not they violate any
journalistic ethics and then you'll get
a score of like x out of 100 articles
we're considered ethical by spj
standards and then we'll break down our
reasoning link to the stories it's going
to be fantastic with your support we can
do more stuff like that so like this
video subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends let's talk
about this first big story because this
is this is really really fascinating
we've got from timcast.com
over 900 pages of coronavirus research
info at chinese lab released following a
foia lawsuit documents regarding the
work of the wuhan institute of virology
are now public the 900 pages of
documents were obtained by the intercept
through ongoing freedom of information
act litigation against the national
institutes of health the collection
includes specific information regarding
eco-health alliance a us-based health
organization and its use of federal
funding to to research bat coronaviruses
the outlet also received two grant
proposals funded by the national
institute of allergy and infectious
diseases gary ruskin executive director
of the u.s right to know said this is a
road map to the high-risk research that
could have led to the current pandemic
but instead of taking it from tmps.com
or i mean and with all due respect this
is information coming from the intercept
who did the work on this one my respect
we have this statement
from richard h ebright verified on
twitter so you know he's legit
board of governors professor of
chemistry and chemical biology at
rutgers
he cites the articles and then
some uh quotes from the article and then
says
the materials show the 2014 and 2019 nih
grants to eco health with subcontracts
to the wuhan institute of virology
funded gain of function research as
defined in federal policies in effect in
2014 and 2017 and potential pandemic
pathogen enhancement as defined in
federal policies in effect in 2017 to
present
he says this has been evident previous
from uh evident previously from
published research papers that credited
the 2014 grant and from the publicly
available summary of the 2019 grant but
this now can be stated
uh definitively from progress reports of
the 2014 grant and full proposals of the
2017 grant
and he ends by saying this because we're
going to read through everything but it
is
particularly damning
the documents make it clear that
assertions by the nih director francis
collins and the niaid director anthony
fauci that the nih did not support gain
of function research or potential
pandemic pathogen enhancement at the wu
hunt institute of virology are
untruthful to put it very simply he is
saying fauci lied francis collins lied
and now i think most of us realized this
but uh
well now we have the documents what i
think is particularly fascinating is is
the intercept of all places that that
published this and so
for what it's worth we'll kick it off
with uh something i saw from glenn
greenwald
he said if he was going to make a bet it
was that they were trying to actually
defend fauci and they may have
accidentally just proven he lied
i don't know what your thoughts on this
matter uh
zed
yeah i mean i can only speculate about
why they did it because um i wasn't in
touch with any of these reporters i
still know some people over there but i
wasn't in touch with any reporters who
did this story um i do think though that
if that's what they were trying to do it
you know it speaks well to them that
they would publish anyway i think we
need more of that in journalism is that
you have a certain worldview or you have
a certain hypothesis about the world you
go out there you look for evidence and
maybe what you find disproves that but
you publish it anyway i mean that's what
they do in science what scientists are
supposed to do is what the peer review
process and the journal process is all
about and so i think if that is what
glenn is saying is true it would
actually speak well of the intercept
that they decide to publish something
that goes against their worldview which
unfortunately i think is something that
you see less and less of in a lot of
these outlets these days you mean like
real journalism yeah i mean it's
literally journalism is about you know
journalism comes from the world journal
it comes from the word journaling
meaning that you're describing or or
you're narrating the world as it is in
front of you uh you don't really do that
when you start leaving out facts when
you start skewing things towards a
particular perspective there is a place
for that it's called advocacy right it's
called activism it's what politicians do
it's what people who are lobbyists do or
people in the nonprofit world often do
and that's fine and it's even i would
say i would even argue it's fine to have
journalists who have that particular
perspective and are going to go out from
that point of view but it becomes a real
problem with so much of the journalistic
world has converted itself into activism
because you're not getting people who
are just calling balls and strikes
you're not getting people who are
willing who have the resources and the
procedures and credibility to go out and
find the facts who will actually be able
to report them even if they go against
those preconceived notions or world
views it's kind of a damning uh
it's kind of a condemnation of activism
the idea that activists who are
supposedly fighting something good are
lying to you i mean that's just that's
just reality right maybe propaganda is a
better word for it you know i'd like to
imagine that as an ad
as an activist if you come across
information that disproves what you're
trying to push you'd be like oh i was
wrong about that
i once did fundraising for an
environmental nonprofit they gave us
information on deepwater horizon they
sent us out to the streets to go ask
people for money because they're like we
want to raise awareness like literally
on the ground telling people as an oil
spill and then i was reading what they
had given us in terms of you know their
script and everything and then some guy
stopped and said you're lying that's not
what happened here's the news here's
what happened and i was like for real
like
when i called my bosses and said hey
this is not true they said oh just keep
reading it anyway you're fine and i was
like what if we're not out here to tell
the truth
to tell people there's a problem and
we're misinforming them why would i do
this and so i was like nah
sorry i'm out
yeah i mean i think that
when you have activists you have
advocates yeah generally speaking it
would be frowned upon just be outright
making things up or lying but i do think
they tend to just by the nature of their
job they tend to skew the truth or they
tend to arrange facts in a certain way i
i mean i wouldn't expect like the nra to
start saying okay well here's all the
the flaws with having liberal gun policy
or like letting everybody own a gun and
i wouldn't expect the brady control to
be saying here's 10 reasons why you
might want to own a gun for self-defense
right like we all anticipate that but
what happens when you start seeing like
cnn or the associated press taking more
strident ideological or partisan
positions and they start being the ones
who won't be telling you both sides of
the story i think that is when it really
gets dangerous for democracy absolutely
yeah and and let's let's throw it back
to these fact checks on on this
reporting when rand paul was clashing
with with dr fauci the craziest thing to
me is that rand is literally like here's
a study it says something like rich gene
pool back chronovirus or whatever and
he's like it says in the study that you
were making chimeric viruses you were
increasing infectivity and this was
funded by you it says nih and then fauci
is like no that wasn't gain of function
and the way i described is like imagine
if a guy was on trial for theft
and he says your honor i didn't steal
that piggy bank from that man's house i
simply walked into his house without
permission took the piggy bank and
walked out with it that's not theft like
you you literally just defined theft
right but what what do we end up seeing
a bunch of fact-checking outlets
misrepresenting what rand paul said many
left or liberal establishment outlets
started saying fauci owns rand paul and
they were highlighting a lot of things
like fauci saying you have no idea what
you're talking about instead of actually
the merit of this research study the
craziest thing was how reddit which is
like just bots basically reddit is a
bunch of bots who just pump stories to
push propaganda and there were still
people breaking through being like i'm
confused why we're mad at rand paul here
he's right the study says you know that
this happened
so
this is what's crazy to me
it's good the internet's published this
it's like like you said it actually
reflects well upon them if they were
actually doing this to prove rand paul
wrong they decided to publish anyway
buzzfeed's done similar things where
they just they publish good stories
but what happened what do we say about
all these outlets that dismiss the story
as fake news as they've been doing with
basically everything like hunter biden's
son like what does that what does that
say about journalism today
yeah and i think this is like a big
theme of a lot of our recent posts that
at inquiremoor.com which is a substance
that we hold uh that we run um which is
that i think that a lot of journalists
now
you know they're having to choose
between two missions one mission is
basically the traditional journalism
going out discovering things about the
world uh describing it as the as the
facts as they see them
the other one is to promote a certain
worldview to promote a certain set of
values right and so i think that if
something like a virus has become
politicized which it has been in the
united states there's actually like a
red position and a blue position a
democratic position a republican
position and everything copy related now
unfortunately
more so here in this country than
anywhere else in the world i'd say also
which is an unfortunate aspect of it now
that you have journalists who kind of
adopted this sort of post-journalist
post-journalism mindset which is
basically an advocacy or an activist
mindset i think they see their goal and
their role as basically debunking or
disproving whatever this quote-unquote
republican position on coronavirus is we
saw this earlier in the pandemic when
they were all making fun of the idea
that a lab leak may have been
responsible for the pandemic now we
don't know where chromatovirus or
kovid19 came from we strictly speaking
we don't know we don't have the evidence
for it but they were so quick to dismiss
this theory
and now you know even the biden
administration's keeping an open mind
about it even they have have uh not
reached a firm conclusion on whether or
not that's true with the might of you
know i have more than a dozen
intelligence agencies looking at it so i
think
that when you have journalists adopt
hard positions rather than keeping an
open mind rather than curious and uh
actually working to discover the world
and report out the facts you do get
things like a rand paul being mocked and
made fun of because they they made you
know they made up their minds before
that hearing ever happened that they
were going to take faulty side they're
going to be against rand paul they're
going to poke poke holes in rand paul's
argument they weren't going to do it in
fauces arguments um and that prevents
them from actually being able to do what
was done in this case with the hundreds
of pages of documents that were obtained
through the foia by the intercept was to
actually go and look at the facts and
see what happened literally see what
happened and tell people what happened
and don't have an opinion about it don't
tell people how they should feel but
literally give them the information that
you any any reasonable person would need
to know how to how to think about this
problem or how to think about the actual
origins of this virus there is still a
challenge with this report and that's
who who was chosen by the outlet
as an expert
and so this this uh we're sitting here
being like wow you know this this
professor at rutgers has said these
things that are untruthful and of course
there's confirmation bias there there
have been several instances where we
have seen experts chosen because their
expert opinion might fit a specific
narrative now this one's interesting
because the intercept had no reason to
choose a professor who would actually
say you know fought you lied so in fact
i have reason to believe this is likely
the case likely true
if you've like you you see this all the
time
where they'll be like you know a
feminist professor agrees with us that
feminism is good and i'm like yeah okay
well that's obvious isn't it or you know
this this critical race theorist
proponent is quote is considered an
expert on this release of documents and
they're going to say something positive
but when you see
a left or right wing outlet
actually saying hey the other side's
actually right on this one or this
here's evidence suggest i'm like that's
probably when it's true like it's so
glaringly true this story that even the
intercept had to be like
yeah vouchy lie i mean they don't but
here's here's the best part the
intercept doesn't mention fauci they
don't mention he lied they just say hey
here's some information
and then
when you read it you're like wait a
minute sounds like fauci lied
is the guy gonna get arrested charged
probably not
because i i guess we don't have
accountability in this country but i
will say
you know you you when you're talking
about journalism
i don't i don't know what happened but
maybe journalists didn't do enough to
inspire the the true tenets of
journalism in the younger generation or
the activists got into colleges and
turned j-school into activism
indoctrination camp or something look i
think part of this wasn't you know i was
working at think progress which was like
a left-leaning blog in 2009 which is
part of a left-leaning think tank and i
think a big part of it was that we had a
frustration always that we felt like the
news would be reporting two sides you
know side a says something side b says
something i know side b totally lied but
the news didn't really call them on it
the news just kind of weighed them
equally and you know they call that
false equivalents and so on and so forth
and there were times i think when news
outlets were doing that they were
getting stories very wrong just because
they weren't actually investigating what
was true because they were trying to
trying to provide balance to the story
but i think they over corrected for a
lot of that by basically saying that we
have we're basically now offering a
justification for being openly biased
right one side is clearly wrong there's
no point to go to them and get comment
from them there's no point to go and
even investigate whether what they said
is true they're clearly wrong just as
just as most of the press said that it
was clearly wrong that there was a lab
leak that resulted in covid19 which is
conclusion now that even the
intelligence community says is actually
possible they don't have the they don't
have a firm conviction on it so i think
that one there was an over correction
and two i think that it's just a reality
that
a lot of the younger generation tends to
be left-leaning and i think that those
are the sorts of people that tend to go
into these industries or these fields if
you go to your average publication even
if it's something very mainstream like
abc news or cnn i will tell you like
nine out of 10 people who work their
vote for democrats you know or they're
left-wing or they're liberals and i
think that just having that level of
like you know cloistered communities of
people makes it much easier
to just become very biased and not have
anyone call you on it not have anyone
push back and not have anyone at least
provide a dissenting opinion even if
like i would say 60 percent of
journalists were left-leading or
liberals it'd probably still be okay
because you'd still have enough like
conservative leaning people around or
people who have an open mind towards
that point of view to say hey you need
to consider x y or z or we need to go
and interview one additional person here
to provide that alternative point of
view but i think when it's so
overwhelming in a lot of these
institutions and institutions that feed
journalism you know for instance i wrote
a report
actually for the intercept a few years
ago about how
the majority of editors and reporters at
the new york times uh in the wall street
journal both came from a small sliver of
elite colleges like and we're talking
about i don't know how many colleges
whether it's probably under 30 or
something like they come from a very
tiny slice a tiny educational and
cultural segment of the united states
and i think when you're so closer when
you're so segregated from the rest of
the country it becomes much easier to
develop group think it becomes much
easier uh to avoid any kind of
dissenting opinion or at least one
person in the room is going to stand up
and say hey we need to consider this
other other side of this we need to
report the other side of it because
otherwise we're not telling the whole
story because i think a lot of these
journalists honestly do think they're
telling the entire story they think what
they're saying is completely
uncontroversial and you have to be kind
of nuts to disagree that's that's
honestly what they think i don't think
it's a conspiracy it's just like a
confluence of of these kind of
influences and these kind of cultures i
don't know i think a lot of them have uh
gone off like i think a lot of them are
evil right and and i'll break that down
because evil is not a light word to
throw around i mean they they actively
understand their omitting information
like the daily beast for instance like
the daily beast is just notorious
there's no way some of these articles
that come out you're going to tell me
this guy believes he's telling the truth
because some of these things that are
said are so
absurd on their face you're like how is
that even no but they'll write it
they'll publish it because their lawyers
tell them like yeah you'll be safe on
that one when you see when you see these
publications
putting out things that are just so over
the top you're like how could that
possibly be true but they don't care
they don't i don't think they think
they're telling the truth
well i think that there's probably two
things happening simultaneously one i
think there's a lot of these news
outlets have shifted to basically
subscriber
kind of uh you know this is a subscriber
business model because the advertising
business model was being basically
dominated by a few digital firms like
google and facebook and so they wanted
subscribers new york times shifted
heavily towards subscribers after trump
was elected so one they have a financial
incentive to cater to a certain world
view and a certain type of person
that person is not going to complain
that much if they get stories wrong as
long as those stories have the right
sort of like you know oh you smeared a
republican who cares the republicans are
all evil anyway they probably deserve
they had it come right right so that's
happening and at the same time they're
hiring up people who legitimately
believe a lot of these things right who
really deeply firmly believe that even
if their story isn't 100 fair
it overall is going in the right
direction so i'll give you an example um
you know ivermectin which is this drug
uh some people are using it for covid19
uh it's being called a horse dewormer or
a horse drug in a lot of like major
press a major mainstream media i
criticized this
um and there were journalists who are
very defensive and saying okay maybe
it's not exactly right that's just a
horse drug okay maybe it's used for
humans sometimes and it's prescribed for
parasitic diseases but the other side is
just taking you know the other side just
crazy they're all conspiracy nuts so
like they see themselves as part of an
ideological battle as long as they're on
the right side of that
if even if they're not being 100 fair
honest journalists they still see
themselves as morally justified i think
that's why they don't see themselves as
evil activism so so here's where i fall
with the whole ivermectin thing
there's conflicting studies data is
inconclusive fda has not authorized or
approved its use pertaining to coven but
the world health organization says that
it's an essential medicine that it's
used for treating river blindness that
it's basically eradicating this one
parasite and there are people who are
doing i think people who are eating
horse paste are absolutely wrong to do
it and you know what we know they're
doing it because we had dr chris
martinson come on this show and say that
people were going to tractor supply and
doing and i'm like you shouldn't do that
there's a lot of reasons why you
shouldn't do that but to then go out and
say joe rogan announced he's taking a
horse dewormer it's like no he didn't
because there's tractor supplies horsty
warmer and then there's going to
walgreens to pick up your prescription
your doctor told you to get now it's
getting so over the top that there's
apparently reports that certain
pharmacies won't even fill prescriptions
like yo pharmacist you don't know what
the prescription's for if a doctor
prescribes it just
say okay you're not the doctor
but that's the problem of
hyperpolarization that we're seeing but
let's
we'll jump to this story because we have
an actual uh a pretty good example
oh i'm so happy to be using this source
from gawker.com
i love it gawker as you may know is back
for like the second time i think or like
you know it's
a hulk hogan peter thiel lawsuit gawker
collapses it tries to relaunch it fails
it relaunches again
gawker of course is mostly not
great journalism
but i want to use this source because i
find it to be just so um
funny
gawker says
rachel maddow wards off this info with
disinforming tweet glenn greenwald is
right about this one i love that they're
insulting glenn green greenell in this
they say something has happened a rare
thing that used to happen all the time
but now arrives roughly every 18 months
like a solar eclipse glenn greenwald has
posted something factually correct and
only minimally annoying specifically
yesterday he tweeted about the rachel
maddow show
rachel maddow tweeted quote patience
overdosing on ivermectin backing up
rural oklahoma hospitals ambulances
quote the scariest one i've heard of and
seen is people coming in with vision
loss he said
glenn greenwald says rolling stone has
now issued a second update that
effectively retracts its false story
that gunshot victims are waiting in er
rooms in oklahoma due to overflow from
ivermectin poisoning yet maddow still
has her tweet up from four days ago
promoting it with no subsequent note
last week the msnbc pundit boosted a
hoax story on ivermectin overdoses
joining a slew of liberal media outlets
in mindlessly digesting the disputed
news and another stern missive about
cover-related information in her rush to
warn viewers of the dangers of
misinformation she did not have time to
fact-check oh that's that's a bit
generous like she ever does come on
unlike several other outlets maddow
still hasn't deleted updated or
clarified the error
the original story came from a local nbc
affiliate all right so let's break this
one this one down really quickly a
doctor says he was misquoted he wasn't
saying that all of these hospitals were
overflowing the beds he's saying there
were some sometimes that there were some
congestion and some of it was because
one guy may have taken too much ever
mectin
they ended up issuing the northeastern
health system sequoia ended up issuing a
statement saying the guy doesn't work
for us we have not treated anybody for
ivor macden the story is fake news
and yet
rachel maddow still has it up now here's
what here's what i love hey good job
gawker i don't know why they're
insulting glenn greenwald he's right you
know
sure i guess they're trying to be edgy
but i'll tell you this
if gawker
can come back
and insult people they don't like and
and whatever but still be correct
i welcome it entirely by all means they
can call glenn greenwald every name in
the book that's wonderful if the facts
are true and correct now what i'll say
about this is
my friends i have seen stories and heard
anecdotes of people eating this horse
pace stuff
don't do that
because what people here's the problem
the stuff from the store that people
don't understand it's uh it's it's this
tube is for a 1 250 pound horse
what they're saying with what these with
this doctor saying is not that you know
all ivermectin is horse dewormer like
the media is doing they're saying some
people went to tractor supply
bought this stuff ate a whole tube that
was meant for a 1 000 250 pound horse
that's insane
right and then they get sick because of
it
now i don't know exactly what's
happening after the fact they're saying
people get vision loss and there's some
crazy stories but i got to tell you it's
really hard to believe some of the over
over the top stories because of how much
the media's lied how many how much we've
heard from like lying nurses there was
one nurse who was like
someone came in held my hand and said i
wish i had been vaccinated before they
passed and tell his family and then
someone looked up that there was like no
one no one in these age groups who had
died in these hospitals like a lot of
these stories are completely exaggerated
the problem is we got two things going
on
the media is going completely over the
top calling all ivermectin horse
dewormer like when joe rogan says he's
taking it clearly it came from a doctor
and they're conflating that with people
eating horse paste
so then you get people on one side who
are like i tell you this there are
people who just adamantly believe
hyperbolicity is is this gift and it's
great and there's there's we have we
don't really have great conclusive we
don't have conclusive data on this right
now we've got some studies
some promising studies some inclusive
studies and a whole lot of me being like
yo if i'm gonna be honest with you i
honestly don't know
brett weinstein can say one thing that's
fine
but we just don't know and so ultimately
what ends up happening is you've got
something that's not fda approved not
fda authorized and there's a lot of
arguments about why that is or isn't but
ultimately i just i defer to the slew of
studies that have conflicting
information
and then you get the culture war in this
saying people who believing and i've met
and saying the media is lying therefore
it must be true people on the left
saying ivermectin is horse dewormer and
mocking everybody ignoring the actual uh
nuance of the whole situation
and then youtube banning people who dare
talk about it so at this point i'm just
basically like yo i don't even care
anymore like youtube has gone so off the
rails they've they gave crowder a strike
for citing the cdc i don't know how we
navigate this other than just talking
about it and just saying what you know
what we think i mean this this oklahoma
story in particular because we just
wrote a post about that at the sub stack
on inquire and
you know when when you when you just get
the details of the story like if you
read like the you know five sentence
summary of it it doesn't sound
believable right rural oklahoma is being
overwhelmed with gunshot victims
and and those victims cannot get into
the hospitals because so many people are
taking this ivermectin which is a drug
that honestly most people probably have
never even heard of i mean unless you're
really plugged into following all this
but never heard of it um and yet this
story not only did it get tweeted by
rachel maddow it got featured on joy
reid's msnbc show the rolling stone
insider it was all over the place like
it was all over the world it's viral if
you go to the hospital's website now
they have a huge splash page up that
says hey look we're taking people we're
not overwhelmed don't worry about being
turned away which is very important
because rural hospitals are a real asset
to those communities you might have to
drive five hours to get to another
hospital because there aren't that many
hospitals in these world rural
communities in rural areas so actually
it's kind of a dangerous thing for
people people to believe that you can't
get to the hospital so what i did what i
did i just called and i sent an email to
the local police and the sheriff and i
asked him like dude what's this story
all about are you guys having a bunch of
gunshot victims what's up uh and the
sheriff in sequoia county in oklahoma
told me no it's a ridiculous story we've
only had we've had one shooting victim
who died this year and we had one other
gunshot victim who went to the hospital
he's treated and he's fine so literally
you know there's two people who are shot
this entire year in this county they're
not overflowing gunshot victims and yet
why was the media running this story
because it confirmed a bunch of biases
you know you got the yokel the rednecks
all shooting each other with their guns
yes with their guns
and they're all eating horse face
because they're really stupid you know
beautiful so of course it's true we
don't have to call a hospital we have to
call the sheriff i'm just asking whether
it's true how much
so so so is that this this must have
been uh an extremely rigorous
investigation you must have put a 200
000 budget behind this i mean how much
time did it take uh to pick up your
phone and press a few digits probably
took me you know between all the emails
and calls probably took me half an hour
to figure this out right
as a freelancer writing on my substance
with one other friend who kind of looks
over my stuff right i don't have the
resources of msnbc or rolling stone or
insider or all the places that ran this
story
but what i do have is this idea that
journalists should tell the truth and
get the facts
and that even if people shouldn't be
taking ivermectin unless it's prescribed
by their doctor and it's going to be
prescribed for things besides kobe
because it hasn't been approved for
covid um we shouldn't lie about whatever
mechanism what it's doing you know you
should never lie i think our our top our
utmost
look
i think there's a lot of journalists who
think if tomorrow they told people that
you would explode if you took ira mectin
they would do it because
they're doing it they're they're now
putting out a story that says 85 percent
of people
in nigeria
who took iron magnum were sterilized and
that is not
true but you have to understand why they
think this is justified they think
because they have this overall activist
goal of not having people take this drug
because because overall i think the drug
is harmful for you so because of that
fudging facts are not quite getting it
right it's it morally pales in
comparison
you know to what to what might actually
happen in their minds that people take
the drugs so to them the telos or the
the goal of truth has been supplanted by
this larger moral goal of taking the
correct position on code we're taking
the correct position on on ivermectin
and this exact bug of post journalism as
narrative journalism has infected so
many different parts of the media
industry right now to where i think
we're going to continue to see stories
like this over and over and over because
again a lot of journalists they don't
care about telling the whole truth about
something they just want to tell you
enough information to achieve whatever
goal there there they want and that's
not very different from what the nra and
the brady campaign do when they're
arguing about gun control or any other
type of activism
let me pull up this tweet i was just
digging around for
so this guy tweets today i learned
ivermectin apparently sterilizes the
majority 85 percent of men that take it
now this guy's not a journalist he's an
activist and there are a bunch of
activists pushing this out and i don't
see journalists pushing this this
narrative out but this just it goes to
show you the gradient between activists
and journalists and how news
organizations have become activists but
they still won't go too far
so there is a a study that i think
looked at 385 people in nigeria and then
they reduced it down to like 37 people
and then tracked their sperm counts
it turns out that nine of those people i
guess or whatever the number was were
were unaffected or something so the
overwhelming majority or maybe i don't
know maybe the wrong number i don't know
all you need to know is
it's a study
it is a tiny sample it is inconclusive
activists are sharing it clearly to
smear this medication
here's what i need to understand about
how deep this lie cuts
these tweets are going viral it's this
tweet has 7
500 retweets from this guy
it is it is insane to state this you
want to know why it's insane
the lie that they are pushing is not
about ivermectin and sterilizing people
if what they're claiming is true
it would mean that the world health
organization
has been administering millions of doses
of a drug sterilizing black men in
africa
now that is an insane proposition which
i i think is over the top the world
health organization has ivermectin on
its list of essential medications for
curing river blindness
99 because i looked this up i went to
the world health organization 99 percent
of river it's um
uh
i'm i can't say it river behind this
river blindness there you go
psoriasis or something anyway 99
are in impoverished african communities
that's where they're saying we need to
be giving ivermectin specifically for
this parasite now if it was true that
there was a study showing it was
sterilizing these people what do you
think these people would start doing i
mean i'm sorry not even if it was true i
mean it's a horrifying prospect about
the what what these people think the
world health organization is doing which
they're not doing tons of people who are
like rest assured these people are
having healthy families and babies this
is a lie
but now look at the fake news imagine
somebody's living in africa
and they know somebody with river
blindness and these these activists are
putting out lies to thousands upon
thousands of retweets
and these people have the internet and
what happens when someone says look look
look look it's it's it's it's gonna hurt
you the the the the white people are
coming and they're gonna hurt you and
they stop taking it because when ebola
when ebola broke out
there were uh so i know journalists who
went and covered ebola they they went on
the ground in some of these villages
and people would break out of quarantine
because they thought the doctors coming
to treat them were actually hurting them
and they were all superstitious and they
believed that you could transfer the
curse and things like that
if you have impoverished and uneducated
villages and we are desperately trying
to help cure their elements and educate
them and teach them
what happens when these activists are
pumping out insane lies
rachel madhouse lies when they're saying
that that ivorbackton's a horse dewormer
all of those lies from the media are
going to be scaring people who were
already worried about being manipulated
you've already got you know joe biden
talking about the tuskegee experiments
granted tuskegee airmen
you know but you get the point and by
the way like the new york times had an
article about the percentage of young
african-americans uh in new york city
who have been vaccinated i think it's
something like 27 or something when they
wrote it it's probably gotten higher
since then
but they interviewed some people and
some people were saying you know why am
i scared of code i'm way more scared
getting shot by the police it's like oh
you know the the news media spent you
know 18 months or so or i don't know how
long but around that probably longer if
you count back out to 2014 or ferguson
telling people to be scared to death of
getting shot by the cops particularly if
you're african-american uh now you have
people going around and just random
people are a big interview on the
streets i know i'm way more scared of
being chopped by the cops and i am
bicombat you know like 700 000 people in
the united states have been killed by
covet 19 right
around a thousand people a year are shot
and killed by police officers i mean
it's very easy math to say that cobit is
much much bigger risk than police
shootings but i think if you went back
to these journalists who promoted a lot
of police shooting stories and asked
them well why didn't you at least put
some statistical context in there why
don't you do this why don't you do that
they'd probably say are you minimizing
you know the shooting of black men by
police officers i'm like no i just want
you to report the truth i want you to
report the totality the context it's
just the statistical data that would let
people know like what act what the
actual risk looks like for them because
it has it has a real practical meaning
to people's lives
yeah one of the things we've talked
about quite a bit is that you've got
kids growing up with facebook being
inundated with nothing but videos of
police brutality and then genuinely
believing that
cops are doing this every day they're
actively seeking people out i mean we've
heard blm activists say like oh they're
hunting us down
and that's just not true but i don't
think it's as
activisty
i mean maybe it is maybe it's activists
who are watching i imagine you're 10
years old you're inundated by nothing of
these with these videos and now you're
18 20 or in college you get out you go
get a job at you know vox or whatever
and you believe it so you start writing
it
but i do think there's a lot of people
when they give you their excuses and
justifications it's because they're
grifters it's because they're like dude
i got two million clicks on that my boss
paid me a bonus
i'm not going to admit i did wrong right
these people are unwilling to correct
the record because
it's the rage that gets them the traffic
now me
i gotta be honest
i think what gets me the traffic is
admitting when i'm wrong i think the
viewers we have are specifically here
because we do corrections and we will
admit we're wrong and i'm really strict
with timcast.com on like
any change anything punctuation i want
to note saying what we changed and why i
want a record of that so people go go
there can see it
media doesn't do that
i think you've got true believers who
have been indoctrinated and i think
you've got
i think the grifters are on the way out
to be honest
and now you're getting true believers
coming in they've they've eaten their
own you know they've fed this refuse to
the children and that's probably why i
don't get journalists anymore you get
activists well you know there was an
analogy i i did some work for an
organization that was uh headed by
jonathan hayes a social psychologist
there's a really good analogy for
changing your beliefs instead of
thinking about a as a switch like okay i
either believe this or i believe that
it's on and off think about it like a
dimmer right like oh i'm maybe 70 sure
about this thing but you know i can i
can change it to 50 and someone gives me
some new information some new evidence
because it really is about tying up with
your ego and i think you're exactly
right that like when we have response
systems now or like gamified you know we
have a gamified world where you're given
a certain amount of like you know
happy feelings um from taking a certain
position from making a certain stance
from describing the world in a certain
way you don't want to lose those
feelings by saying ah maybe i was wrong
maybe i should change my mind about this
maybe it's a little bit different we've
set up incentive systems that make us
behave in like really anti-social and
like anti-intellectual ways and i think
your practice that you just described is
very healthy it's like you're setting up
a new incentive system for yourself
you're saying actually my viewers really
like appreciate it when i admit that
maybe i you know i was wrong about
something or maybe it's a little bit
different than i thought before my
opinions change um not all the time
but periodically like uh you know
fairly absolute on 2a you know i i used
to be like well there's got to be some
things we can do we need to have
conversations there's urban versus rural
and now i'm just this point where i'm
like everybody gets guns government
should be giving guns away for free give
everybody a gun um i'm i'm half kidding
i don't i i i do argue and this is
important why the government should give
away free guns
is that
the right never fights for anything
and and they say you know a lot of the
conservatives are like it's because we
don't think the government should be
providing these things and i'm like well
here's the imbalance
the the left will demand universal
health care they'll demand government do
things for them and then all the
conservatives will do is say
no
conservatives never actually advocate
for things on their own within reason
it doesn't it doesn't have to be about
giving someone something but i'm
actually
taking this from michael malus god we
quote this guy too much um but he said
the left advocate demands universal
health care the right doesn't demand
universal gun access
but i will say the real argument is
where are the republicans coming out and
demanding a repeal of the national
firearms act where the conservatives
coming out and saying we don't want the
government to do things we want to
produce they don't do that so you end up
with the left constantly demanding
things and taking it and the right doing
a whole lot of just saying stop yeah i
mean i've written a couple pieces
actually for the washington examiner
which is like a dc based magazine that's
right-leaning it's like kind of center
right or right of center
about sort of the debates within the
conservative movement about where their
governing philosophy should be going in
the next few years and i think for many
years the conservative movement has
basically been tantamount
in many ways the libertarian movement
right like their their general
philosophy is government should take
their hands off stuff uh we should spend
less money we should have less
regulations and we should just uh
embrace personal responsibility and
individual freedom
i think there is a rethink happening
about that and in many parts of the
right right now it's not a dominant
philosophy it's not something you'd see
the mccarthys and mcconnells of the
world embracing but i do think you're
seeing some people in the senate in the
house and a lot of people on the
intellectual right starting to say hey
look uh we can't really respond to the
collapse of the family by just talking
about another tax cut right right you
know it's not that you should never cut
taxes should never deregulate anything
but there has to be kind of a broader
kind of social and political and
economic agenda than i think just the
libertarian mottos and it's really
interesting and kind of what you just
said about guns because i think
one one way that gun policy may be
different in some parts of the world is
that they
you know like gun ownership in a place
like switzerland right like people
it's not super unusual to like have
have like training for your firearm to
have a firearm they often keep them
locked up or they get the ammunition
separate or something but like they they
see they don't necessarily see it as
antagonistic to gun rights to have the
government involved in it at some level
whereas here in the u.s the debate's
very polarizing there's some people who
just absolutely hate guns i don't think
anyone should own one and there's other
people who just you know they think
everyone and their mom and their baby
should own a gun but like they aren't
necessarily saying okay the government
should put together uh you know a really
cool training course and give it to
people give it to kids when they hit
high school in this rural area where a
lot of people own guns and like actually
get
um you know get people's buying and
confidence and get like people who are
not gun enthusiasts thinking okay
there's a way they can use these things
safely and there's a way we can make
sure people have access to them and good
training and so on and so forth yeah the
gun thing i think is
one of the most glaring examples of
the media lying and having no or having
no idea what they're talking about and
so like very early on in the gun debate
i just would do basic research as a
journalist and i tried to learn more and
more and more about how you know wrong
the media was they're still wrong to
this day constantly saying things that
make no sense advocating for the ban of
things that don't do anything
uh the example i love to give is that in
maryland the m1a is banned as an assault
weapon but the scar 20s is not and for
people who know anything about guns
you'd probably be like that's a weird
thing to do because the m1a is it's a
great weapon but the scar 20s is more
customizable adaptable easier in a lot
of ways i suppose but just more modern
and and better and i guess depending on
who you ask some people might like the
m1a
but the fact of the matter is this is
what you get from immediate
disinformation
you get policies that make no sense and
you get the escalation
and the indoctrination so actually taxes
are a really great idea we talked about
taxes quite a bit i think ian you were
the one mentioning that like early on
the first income tax was like two
percent or something oh i don't know the
number
i think we were having a conversation a
while ago and you were like initially
the income tax was going to be like it
was only for the rich and it was only
supposed to be like two percent and they
were like it's just the rich it won't
affect you and now here we are with like
35 to 45 total taxes not just income tax
like i think they say the average person
will pay 45 of their income in taxes
when it comes to sales tax property tax
you know gas taxes whatever food
sales all that stuff and it used to be
none
but what happens is
they'll come out and they'll say you
know we just want this teeny bit you
give an energy to take a mile that's why
the gun the gun rights advocates in this
country are adamant about giving nothing
away
because they know that it's just
chipping away at the block and
eventually it's it's all gone did you
look it up yeah it was three percent
1861 president lincoln and that
eventually i believe got repealed to
later get recreated by the federal
reserve in 19 was 14 i think 1913
something like that like that
yeah i mean they're they're one of the
issues um where this where this headed
up was school shootings right like
people
i think we had some very high profile
school shootings in the united states
columbine in the 1990s we had new town
in parkland um it's really shocked a lot
of people's conscience it was heavily
covered in the media and i think it
produced a policy response that was he
was very well intended i think people
were legitimately scared for their
children but now i looked it up in like
a majority of states i think around a
majority or at least half actually
require students in schools to do school
shooting drills like off top of your
head do you know how many students die
every year in a school shooting what's
the number it's 10. it's around 10 on
average right it's like and how many
students are there
must be must be 70 75 million something
like that under 18. so
you know school shootings of course are
tragic but what's the impact of having
you know tens of millions of kids you
know hiding in the hallways under desks
being in kind of a war posture right
within their schools even every town
which is one of the gun control groups
did some studies on this and found that
increased anxiety increased depression
and now they're advocating for reform
saying we shouldn't be doing you know
all these all the time because i think
it was a knee-jerk reaction to a highly
charged issue and i think that we've
seen a lot of that during cobit 19 as
well which is where people
i think
you know
one of the phrases that comes to mind is
um better safe than sorry right you know
you can't over protect someone but what
i always say is like
if you're over protecting people from
one thing you could be under protecting
them from another thing right if we if
we install all these measures on
children against something which they
almost
almost completely unlikely they'll ever
face it we may be under protecting them
against things like anxiety depression
you know long-term kind of suicidal
tendencies all kinds of cognitive
distortions about fear of things that
really they shouldn't be all that afraid
of
we're not think you know if you think
entirely about protecting a population
from one thing you can underestimate the
risk from all sorts of other things and
i think reframing it that way might be
one way for us to be able to to rethink
some of these like overreactions to some
of these threats that we we face
historically there's like a
matrix kind of red pill blue phenomenon
i'm seeing from this that's causing
i'll just call it societal collapse and
what i mean to say is
when you're inundated by
a certain subject matter school
shootings police brutality whatever on
social media and then the algorithm
keeps feeding you that content and then
you come to perceive that as the only
existence as the real world
you're basically in this matrix you are
in you're in the algorithm's world
now being fed these stories you'll
immediately become an advocate saying
like we have to stop this and you'll
start giving your energy and power to
politicians who don't actually care to
solve any problems just exploit your
fears
and then there are people who are sort
of
awakened to this right so the blue pill
red pill you're you're in and i'm and i
i i hate the political red pill blue
pill thing but i mean quite literally
like
there's an algorithm at play on social
media
crafting a world for people that makes
no sense because they click on police
brutality and the algorithm says let's
give them more of that it's good for
business for the company that they're on
the website more so let's do more
algorithmic content feeding and then
there are people who are just like i'm
sick of the algorithms i'm just gonna
shuffle it up i wanna i wanna read i'm
gonna investigate on my own and then
they break out of that system and say
hey wait a minute something's not right
here now the problem is we're having
this conversation about
the rarity of school shootings the the
rarity of unarmed black men being killed
by police both both circumstances
extremely awful and shouldn't happen and
we should do what we can to make sure
they don't happen but extremely rare so
for us to put you know 70 something
million kids through school shooting
trainings
because you said what do you say
well
10
i think on average it's ten it may be a
little bit more uh some years and others
but generally speaking more kids die in
pool drownings or in some kind of
drowning like they should swim lessons
would be more useful for children than
school shooting drills but see here's
what happens the people who live in the
matrix in this algorithm you know or
this median narrative or click bait rage
bait gift or whatever
start voting for policies based on a
fake world view that was fed to them to
make money
and that's why i think it's gotten so
substantially worse to the point where
it's like you know we feel like we're at
each other's throats there's there was a
literally uh
shootout this past weekend uh one of the
i guess a proud boy got shot in the they
were shooting at him and he got he took
a bowling leg it was uh i don't know if
he was a proud boy it was the guy tiny i
thought he was patriot pair but people
are saying proud boy and there was a
shootout a couple weeks ago in in
portland as well where thankfully nobody
got hurt
but what happens is
you have people
who will vote
who will run for office
and and it's it's not just like you live
in a matrix where there is an overseer
keep keeping in the matrix like people
believe that they saw the movie
no no no the people who are running the
matrix live in it too
the people who are
taking the blue pill
who believe that there is like a a it's
it's a pandemic of police officers going
around hunting down black people they
run for office based on that and then
try and pass laws based on that
you try and tell them it's not real and
they'll snap at you they'll call you a
nazi a fascist all right they got to
protect that worldview
i don't know how you're breaking it i
mean look i the other day something i've
been writing about is basically pandemic
responses across the world because one
thing i notice is that the u.s response
when it comes to uh children is very
different than most of the world most of
europe australia new zealand uh you know
we're we're acquiring mass in most
school districts in the united states
even for children who are four or five
years old six years old which actually
is much more conservative than what the
recommends it's more conservative than
what the european health agencies are
talking about or most of the australian
districts
and you know
to buttress my argument you know i just
put out a basic graph from the cdc
showing that child
mortality child deaths from covet 19 are
very very small they're a very small
percentage they've generally been the
same throughout the pandemic and you
know the instantaneous response you get
to that is that you're minimizing the
debts of children right i literally
posted the facts straight from the cdc
showing the context of this and i think
that you know part of it is that
i think once you've adopted the activist
mindset of the moralizing mindset you
have one goal in mind and that goal of
course is protecting children from
covenant 19 a totally understandable
goal
but at the same time when you're not
getting the whole picture you're not
looking at all the other possible
ramifications of keeping kids in this
crisis mode for basically forever and
you're not considering the points of
view of other people in the world who
are not doing that you know in british
schools they're not doing that in
australian schools they're not doing
that they're using largely rapid testing
social distancing uh some some
vaccinations at the higher level like 16
and 17 year olds maybe are getting
vaccinations but they're not having
toddlers running around in mass for the
most part
and uk has had the delta variant you
know they've had this experience they've
seen this movie um and yet they're not
doing it i think we're not really giving
any weight to their to their concerns
because we fixated so much on one
problem
and that i think is really you know not
only is it corrupting journalism it's
corrupting society because i think we
need to be well-rounded people right a
bird can't fly with just one wing you
got to have two wings right you got to
be able to understand things from more
than one point of view and you have to
be able to look at more than one problem
in society because i think we've created
a lot of problems for ourselves by not
doing that i think things like
certain kinds of over parenting
certain kinds of over scheduling
children you know i talk to kids these
days about like what they do i do some
community work with children and i talk
to like some kids about
you know what's their summer like and
they're saying oh you know i go to band
camp then i'm at you know algebra class
and blah blah blah they have a full
schedule they're busier than i am during
their summers right that's a huge change
in society you know generational change
versus what it was in the 1990s or early
2000s and you know maybe there are some
positive benefits for that maybe there's
some drawbacks but we have to be able to
look at both sides of it otherwise we're
only seeing half the world and we could
be missing a lot of threats to our
children if we if we continue to to
address or threats to anyone else but
continue to address social problems in
that way
perspective i you know the difficulty is
the hysteria there's money to be made
for the media when a you know a shooting
happens the media says this is big run
it look at look at i don't even saw the
project veritas expose where they had
the cnn guy being like you know we just
run the covet death tracker because it
plays well you know it's like it was
gangbusters for the ratings
that's what they're thinking about and
it drives panic and panic you never want
to panic you panic you cause problems if
you're in a fire the last thing you want
to do is panic you want to be calm
rational be like okay here's what i got
to do here's how i got i got to feel the
door i'm going to get down get under the
smoke all that stuff
instead the media just screams and
everyone's faces at the top of their
lungs screaming panic and then people
panic and then they click more and then
they get more you know they make more
money they make more ads they get more
subscriptions
and it all ends up you know going into
every facet of society it's not just the
media it's now in like uh
regular businesses it's in the medic
it's in like movie theaters it's in uh
um burger joints yeah i mean
and look like panic is part of human
nature for a reason it's an evolutionary
response if you see a saber-toothed
tiger maybe it might be a good idea to
to run and dart in the other way well
but for me to be honest if i saw a
saber-toothed tiger that'd be cool i
mean like whoa that's where they were
extinct that's true
um but that kind of evolution or
response or instinct is only useful in
some select circumstances where you're
really seeing a direct threat in front
of you
complex social problems really never
really they never really benefit from
panicking and if you think about like
who we think of as the great leaders
throughout history whether they're
generals or theologians or activists or
so on and so forth they generally had a
calm thoughtful reasoned response to the
social problems they were dealing with i
mean
we admire the uh sclc and snick and
king's movement um
when if you actually look at some of the
old photos and i think it's actually it
still exists the highly under center in
tennessee where they were training civil
rights activists they would have people
sitting at like a lunch counter a mock
lunch counter someone would be pulling
their hair another person would be
blowing smoke in their face and they
would train them just to like brush it
off just say i don't care i'm going to
keep keep on the course of action right
that's those are the those are the modes
of thinking or the temperament that you
have to adopt when you're dealing with
really complex high pressure problems at
times and i think treating everything
like it's you know the bear just walked
into your camp and you better you better
dart uh leads you astray a lot of the
time and unfortunately i think that we
have so much technology and so much of
the commercial products that we use
today are basically based on using that
kind of response because that's what
they want to bring out of you because
that's what that's what will make the
money
yeah well i don't know how you break
that right if if we i guess that's a
problem of of the free market right that
this system in place makes money
so it is being incentivized you know
i'll i'll go back to what i was talking
about the algorithms feeding kids this
this endless stream of police brutality
stuff
well
companies rose it's very simple company
a and company b start up company a does
legit fact check journalism company b
does rage bait activist stuff which one
made the money
so over over the course of uh six months
the real news website does decently and
the grifter outrage site makes tons of
money and then the investors come in and
say
oh that one makes money let's do that
one and now it's been a decade of this
it's been 13 14 15 years of this and now
we've built this massive ecosystem of
hey we make money when we just tell
people what they want to hear instead of
informing them of the truth
it's not only that they make money doing
that i mean well it's not only that it
generates money generates revenue but
it's also very quick and easy to do
think about how many articles you read
that's like you know three people
tweeted something
it's mildly offensive but by the time
you figure
by time you get through the article it's
going to be super offensive it'll be
like the worst thing in the world to you
um it's super easy to run that article
it probably gets hundreds of thousands
of views if you're putting it up there
it doesn't you don't have to spend money
on investigating spec checking traveling
uh you know foia records request none of
that work it's extremely easy and i
think that's part of why it's profitable
because i do think that like
well-produced good journalism does get a
lot of viewers and readers i think
people enjoy it and appreciate it but
it's also more expensive to do right
which is a challenge i think for a lot
of people who are producing it and
investing in it and unfortunately i
think that's also created a situation
where like a lot of good media isn't
necessarily profitable we are kind of
like at the behest of like
philanthropists and billionaires who
want to spend money promoting something
uh like pierre mittier did with the
interceptor like peter thiel is doing
with some like alternative video
platforms or things like that i don't i
don't think it's all bad uh there was an
episode that uh of joe rogan's show he
did and i think it may have been with
matt tybee i'm not sure where they
mentioned like anybody who goes for
legit journalism right now is probably
going to make a killing you know it's an
and we're already seeing with all these
different sub stacks popping up i mean
glenn greenwald you have substance
michael tracy for instance matt tybee
and apparently they're doing really uh
barry weiss yeah they're all doing
really really well i mean timcast.com is
doing v uh is doing really really well
and so
i will say there's always a challenge in
trying to figure out if you're actually
doing the right job or if you're just
you know partisan but i i think it's
fair to point out
yeah the establishment is just pushing
narratives many of these outlets just
want to stick to their world view side
with the audience they call it and if
their audience is is trapped in a
whirlpool of fake news garbage and
hating someone else siding with the
audience isn't the right thing you want
to do no you want to challenge
well you know you want to challenge that
you want to be honest
so so interestingly you mentioned these
articles where it's like they'll grab a
few tweets and then post an article
being like you know so and so said this
we've actually talked about this at
timecast.com because we've had a few
articles where it's like so and so was
criticized and then we show some tweets
and i'm like
we won't do that and i was like hey
let's talk about this is this is
it might be newsworthy to be fair it
might be because if like a congress
person makes an official statement about
a specific policy that starts a feud or
something and then it's just you're
pulling tweets that may be something
people want to know about but i said
what we should do is
if we see one of these twitter spats
we're not just going to pull up someone
on the right who's saying you know f you
i want to see what the left you know
prominent personalities are saying and
the right and then we want to actually
break down the fact check of who's right
and who's wrong
now that's a little bit more work you
got to actually do some journalism there
but that's the way it should be
conversations are happening on twitter
very important ones it's kind of silly
in some ways but if a congress person is
debating another congress person i think
you know we want to talk about that look
i think part of it also just like
awareness i think we were
i did some work earlier this year for a
guy named justin rosenstein he was an
early google and facebook guy he also
co-founded asana he made like i don't
know he's like probably a billionaire
worth of his asana stock and facebook um
and his conclusion was that he created
all these technologies to help people
cooperate with each other and work
together as teams but they all kind of
went awry everyone hates each other
there's a lot of division and everything
so basically he's giving away a ton of
money through philanthropy and grant
making because he feels guilty about all
this
um
i think that
you know he started this company with he
started these companies with like good
intentions like he was one of the
founders of like the facebook like
button and like i think that they
actively debated whether or not to make
a dislike button but they were like
we're not going to do that because it'll
be negative it'll create negativity
people will get fighting and all that
stuff and but it ended up facebook like
ended up like being pretty bad anyway
because people are using it to share
content this was like dissing someone or
attacking some out group or something
but i think that
you know there are large social and
cultural changes that happen once you're
aware that something is a problem and i
don't think that we looked at
you know the
youtubes and the social medias of the
world and sort of the echo chambers
hyper polarization all this as a problem
until very recently i think even if you
go back to like two thousand nine two
and ten dollars everyone was talking
about how these things were great we
were all communicating with each other
uh they were helping democrats in
elections so democrats liked them versus
how they felt about trump using it in
2016 15 16
or him using twitter
but i think now that we have the
awareness of the problem i kind of feel
like the solutions will bubble up
as
after the awareness is built because i
think that's what's happening with other
technologies that ended up being harmful
for us i think everything from we have
much safer cars now with seat belts and
airbags
to where we have a dramatic decline in
smoking in the united states right
smoking was an addictive product people
was flying off the shelves making people
at altria and so on and so forth tons
and tons of money but i think once we
recognize that it was a problem start
educating people about it
creating some alternatives some minor
regulations i think we actually moved in
a healthier direction and i think
something similar will happen with
social media and a lot of what online
you know
monopolization has done to journalism
and part of that i think is antitrust
like getting very serious about the fact
that these companies basically are the
new standard oil they are the new
railroads and that creating alternatives
to them and creating healthier modes and
models is very very difficult while they
have such high market share and i think
more democrats and republicans uh in in
the congress you have davis cellini
who's the head of the relevant committee
in congress on antitrust and ken buck
who's the ranking republican actually
agreeing on a lot of the core antitrust
issues with a lot of these big companies
um it was funny that like i think a
third of the republicans in the senate
voted for lena khan to join the the ftc
who's a very progressive person who in
many ways has talked about breaking up
companies like amazon or turning them
into public utilities or having utility
regulation uh instead so i think that
we're seeing much more agreement that
these things are a problem and some
agreement on solutions now does that
mean i think that a year or two from now
we're gonna have an entirely different
uh online and social media environment
which i think ultimately would impact
the media environment no but i do think
over the long term having that awareness
and having that recognition is the first
step towards creating something better
this is different though right with with
these past things that were bad for us
asbestos and smoking and lead gas and
stuff like that i mean that was
neutral-ish you it was public interest
versus the special interest that had
money around a specific product or
practice
now you got half the country
so if we're talking about censorship and
you have this major shift where all of a
sudden the the you know more
establishment like i mean like the
neocons and the democrats are basically
in favor of massive multinational
corporations curtailing speech
i don't see us fixing that because that
directly impacts who gets elected in the
first place when jack dorsey can ban
negative news about hunter biden
well then hunter biden's dad gets
elected and depending on what you
believe i mean there was a there was a
survey from rasmussen which found that
if people had been informed because
people didn't know about this when they
learned that hunter biden had done these
things with joe and these these shady
business deals they would not have voted
for him the margin was massive or large
enough to actually question you know it
was like ten percent of people said they
wouldn't have voted for brighton had
they known the truth well we know that
facebook and twitter suppress negative
news about a democratic candidate
that being the case
why would any democrat ever
give in to any kind of legislative
reform over these companies the
antitrust stuff i can see
yes
i don't think i'll solve the problem
though what people need to understand
about facebook and google is that
antitrust makes sense simply because
we're not you know some people say oh
but you know who wants to use a bunch of
different video platforms we're not
saying that youtube is a video platform
adsense is an advertising platform
adwords is is a is an ad uh distribution
platform i mean they're well i think
they change
not now just google ads or whatever but
these are all different products
youtube hosts your video and broadcasts
it
google sells ads on that
google buys you know buys and sells ads
and distrib and distributes them they
also market your content to maximize
viewership these are different companies
in the past you would find someone
record your music you'd find someone to
distribute your mute distribute your
music and then you would find people to
promote your music on the radio today
youtube that's it
youtube hosts and distributes they're
the ones who do all the ad selling and
they're the ones who determine who's
going to be on the front page you could
break them up into three companies
antitrust could come in and say
you know everybody likes youtube because
where the videos are okay youtube you no
longer can do the ads we're breaking
this up into different companies and
then all of a sudden you'd see way more
competition and ad rates probably ad
rates would improve dramatically for a
lot of people you would then get speed
you you would then get people at youtube
basically being like
you know uh
this would be interesting because there
would have to be individual deals
with your channel and youtube as to how
revenue is generated it'd be very very
complicated it may actually even destroy
youtube because i don't know if youtube
is possible if youtube can even function
without subsidy from google in the first
place but that
if that's the case there's a lot of
questions we have to ask about
major companies making tons of money
doing one thing subsidizing and cutting
everyone else from the market by dumping
money into another thing right
so a better example is
i won't name the big chain of coffee
houses of coffee shops just for legal
reasons but
i've heard these stories from local mom
and pop cafes where a big chain shop
opens up next door and sells coffee at
ridiculous prices ridiculously low
because they're well funded by a massive
conglomerate they can sell at a loss
it chokes out the mom and pop shop
because now all of a sudden you've got
people like why spend five bucks on my
cap you know cappuccino when chain store
has it for three bucks
then once mom and pop was out of
business
chain store jacks the prices back up and
now owns 100 of that market share
though that that that's problematic
that's predatory behavior that we see a
lot of i know a lot of people on the
right say that simply just oh it's free
market capitals and they're allowed to
do it and i'm like
i mean that's brutal that's basically
what youtube does
google just dumps money into these
things so facebook for instance the same
thing right facebook is a social network
as well as advertisement advertising
sales and promotion marketing all of
these things i think we could look at
that and find a way to break it apart
yeah i mean i think a lot of this is
going to depend on the right because i
do think that the tech companies had the
mindset that you were describing that if
they aggressively basically took this
the positions and the stances that the
democrats wanted in the 2020 election
he would avoid regulation from the
democrats when they took power um it's
not necessarily a super safe bet because
the democrats have their own grievances
against tech right a lot of them think
that tech doesn't censor enough right
right um and the republicans think maybe
it censors too much but i think they
they run the risk by being so polarized
towards the democrats of actually
radicalizing the republicans so i think
that you know i was when i wrote my most
recent article for the examiner about
big tech and the republicans you know i
asked ken buck's office about you know a
few years ago he was not talking about
breaking up big tech companies he wasn't
even interested in the topic and he was
like yeah i went to a field hearing and
a bunch of my constituents were talking
about amazon and how it was you know it
was making it difficult for them to sell
and like you know the republicans are
noticing what's happening to them right
so it may be that if the republicans
change their political orientation
enough you know if they actually respond
to events and not just respond with a
bunch of slogans and mottos about tax
cuts deregulation but if they actually
see these companies as opposed to their
base and they need to respond to their
base the next time they get enough power
they would conceivably be able to either
through legislation or through
continuing to support people in the
regulatory agencies be able to create
the majority for things like breaking up
the large companies imposing common
carriage rules uh which would help
against a lot of the discrimination and
censorship issues uh interoperability so
that different people users from
different companies can talk to each
other so you know it won't be like okay
i'm on a network with 500 people so i
can't talk to people who use facebook
now you still win with interruptability
so i think that a lot of it really is
the ball being in the republicans court
there are enough
democrats even though democrats are more
pro-censorship who do want to address
the power of these companies for one
reason or another and there are a
growing number of republicans but i
think as long as there's a core group of
republicans
who who's you know their their mantra is
basically to look at what's happening to
their base and do nothing about it which
has been kind of the way they've
responded to a number of social crises
over the past you know generation or so
then i don't think much will happen but
i do think that if somebody like a josh
hawley or a jd vance or some of these
people on the right who are very
enthused about this issue are willing to
work with democrats on the issue you
know holly supported lena connor he
might have been the only biden nominee
that he supported uh who's a very you
know very much to the left on this big
tech issue uh she probably wasn't the
only one but he voted against most of
the nominees so it was rare to see him
support one
i do think if those people
grow in influence and are able to make
that argument to the base and mobilize
that base against the establishment then
you'd really see movement on this issue
i think as long as you see one party
that takes a complete lawsuit fair
attitude towards corporate concentration
which is what the republicans have been
doing you're right probably nothing will
happen but if they change their
orientation and at least a few democrats
are willing to support some reforms then
i think something will probably will
happen
i think we may see a reckoning with the
republicans in the midterms
uh 2016
republicans had everything and they did
nothing in fact many of them supported
the russia gate investigation
then 2018 the democrats you know
recoiling from trump take the house back
then trump loses 2020 joe biden is now
president and we end up with people who
are sick and tired of watching this
problem of social media manipulation big
tech censorship
actually having a major influence on the
election like we mentioned with uh
suppressing negative news about joe
biden's family
and now you have to wonder what's going
to happen with the republican party
there's there's a lot of talk about a
lot of you know right populists who are
now running to primary existing
republicans or you know current
republicans i think you know a lot of
people keep saying oh man the
republicans are going to win the house
in 2022 and they're going to push back
maybe but i also think we're going to
see a lot of uh
establishment republican types
feckless
you know uh laissez faire perhaps is the
way you describe them they do nothing
just whatever goes with these businesses
they're gonna get ousted
i don't know for sure i just think that
the sentiment surely is there to not
just have a sweep of the house but also
a changing of the guard in the
republican party because as it stands we
were mentioning this earlier in the show
republicans don't do anything you know
at least right now right
they're not coming out and saying we
want to repeal firearms legislation the
left is saying we want legit firearms
control we want gun control and the
right's just saying no
where where is any semblance of a
resistance saying we actually want to
repeal some of that legislation doesn't
exist then you have 2016-8 2016 until
today with every trump supporter knowing
this is a problem going back to 2016
complaining about being banned the
censorship getting worse and nothing
getting done about it now all of these
people are probably fed up how stupid
did republican politicians have to be to
ignore a problem that would result in
them actually losing elections
so now you get republicans just
replacing those people let me tell you a
story so you know not only did i work in
journalism i worked directly in advocacy
in earlier in life and you know i was
working for a progressive pack in i
think it was around 2012 2013 uh maybe a
little bit after that um and i was i
went to a progressive conference and
there was a bunch of people in a room
from all range of progressive
organizations
and they were all talking about
protecting social security and medicare
and i was like guys like you can talk
about protecting it all day long or
whatever but you what you need to be
doing is seizing the opportunity to talk
about expanding these programs right
this was 2012 2013 nobody was talking
about doing this um
i think starting six or seven months
later they were members of congress who
started talking about their other
organizations started doing that and i
think the democrats really came to
understand something that if you can
control the playing field of the debate
and not be on the defensive you've
shifted things in your direction even if
you don't exactly get what you want so
now i think when someone like bernie
sanders talks about medicare for all it
gets people excited about that
the chances of there being significant
medicare cuts of raising the retirement
age of different types of privatization
have gone down because now the public
debate is all about whether we should
expand it or not or instead of cutting
it so i think exactly what you just said
the the lack of
a
proactive republican response on so many
different issues allows the democrats to
control the playing field and if i were
the republicans i would think it was a
terrible strategy but i think that's
just been their go-to mode for so long
thinking that you know if we'll just
call the democrat socialists and
communists and gun grabbers that'll win
us every election right and that's just
not the reality in this country anymore
there are a lot of people who are
interested in a lot of progressive ideas
as as i think they should be because i
think some of the progressive ideas are
worthwhile and worth exploring uh but as
long as there's no response that
progresses of course are going to win
the day right you can't just completely
fall back to your to your slogans and
your mottos from 40 years ago when the
world has changed within 40 years here's
the big difference i see right we we
have the squad we have the progressive
left but man do they fall in line really
fast with the establishment democrats
the republicans hate the republican
party like we i i love pulling up these
polls but we go to civics and you can
take a look at their polling it's like
democrat party sentiment and it's like
you know 60 percent of people are i
think they're they're viewed unfavorably
but like 40 percent of them favorably
among democrat voters it's like 80
percent favor the democratic party
among republicans
favorability for the republican party
it's like
50 something percent because like
republicans don't like the republican
party i think that right there from that
polling shows that they're ready to
make a big movement right a big change
that we're going to see a bunch of right
populists primary a bunch of republicans
and then change we'll see we'll see
there's been a lot of talk about i think
i think that the
the energy is out there to do that what
is lacking is probably the organization
so i something that's been really
interesting and again this was in my
examiner article i reported was that
there are some republican politicians
now who are saying they will not take
tech money like if a tech lobbyist or a
pac you know wants to throw them a
fundraiser or give the money they will
not take it the heritage foundation
which is the most establishment you know
voice on the right recently said they
will no longer take any more tech money
now does that mean that the heritage
foundation is completely going with the
populace against establishment i don't
think so policy-wise they haven't
changed that much but it does tell me
that there's a sea change in thinking
among their constituency and among the
party about their relationship to
corporate america to where they actually
said there's actually one corporate
sector at least that they're not going
to be taking money from anymore that's a
huge change from what the heritage
foundation would have been saying 10
years ago so i think
there's a lot of this base sentiment on
the republican right that a lot of their
politicians have not been setting up for
their people have not been saying that
for their bases it just needs to be
organized right a lot of what people
like me on the left were doing years ago
in terms of organizing and changing the
way that the parties kind of address
these issues and tackle them needs to
happen on the right and i think honestly
a lot of the people who've been
controlling
um the policy arena on the right are
just very you know they're very narrow
band of people a lot of them work for
ronald reagan or in that administration
right i think when a new when a new
generation of people takes over they may
be thinking a little bit differently and
i think you're starting to see that when
you look at
uh races like you know um
joe kentz out in washington state where
he's running a primary or jd vance
running in ohio you know i think that
these people see the republican party's
relationship to governance very
differently they think that the
republican party needs to be defending
the interests of the base first and
foremost including by using state action
if necessary rather than adhering to a
sense of you know a sense of principles
or certain tenets about limited role of
government irregardless of what's
happening to the base of the
constituencies of the voters yeah why is
it that you know bernie sanders folds so
quick though right and i mean i i don't
mean him specifically i just mean like
you know we look at 2016 you got bernie
and you got trump the insurgent
candidates trump said excuse me no kicks
the door and says i refuse and takes
over bernie says i'll say whatever you
want hillary and then the progressives
come in and they're like yeah whatever
the establishment wants
well you know the funny thing is as as
effectively as somebody like a hillary
clinton red-baited bernie sanders in
2016 campaign cycle and so on and so
forth i do think that bernie is
fundamentally a team player right like
he's someone who has certain policy
priorities that he works for day and
night and he feels like if he can move
the ball a little bit on them he's
willing to work with just about anyone
that's always been kind of the way that
he's addressed his relationship to the
democratic party even though he's an
independent and i think it was highly
predictable given given the way that he
operated in congress in the 1990s i mean
let's remember when newt gingrich was
running congress the member of congress
who passed the most amendments was
bernie sanders right bernie and newt are
diametrically opposed from each other in
many ways and of course the republicans
were holding congress but bernie sanders
was very very good at working with house
republicans even and getting their votes
on amendments where he felt like maybe
they agree with them on some corporate
welfare issues or some individual
liberty issues and i think that you know
bernie you know despite you know maybe
he's not that great at telling this
story about himself on the campaign
trail but i think within congress people
realize that he's actually a fairly
pragmatic figure he's not really the
revolutionary that i think he often you
know was portrayed as in his campaigns
or some of his base or his or his fam or
his you know really tough fans really
think he is so yeah actually i think it
was the world's the world socialist
website called bernie sanders a
nationalist capitalist and they were
like he's not a socialist he does not
support us he's a nationalist who has
four closed borders and border barriers
and he is a capitalist who wants
business to make money he's just
somewhat more left
that was funny but here's the issue i
take like you you say these stories
about bernie sanders i'm like yeah well
that's why i liked him
liked past tense and then when he
basically you know got his knee and
kissed hillary clinton's pinky ring i'm
like this guy's got no principles i
don't care what he's fighting for he
could have absolutely said i'm not going
to endorse her sorry have a nice day and
that's that's it but instead he was like
whatever the machine needs of me
and now what is he doing i mean this is
a guy who in in
2016 cycles in 2015 said that open
borders is a koch brothers proposal to
you know to exploit these workers and
things like that
and then come to the you know 2020 the
2019 primaries and all stuff he's
talking about open borders and free free
medical care for non-citizens and stuff
he totally flipped on all his positions
you know that's what i see when i see
like the squad aoc man i remember as
soon as she got elected all of a sudden
her stance on palestine and israel
started shifting activists started
getting really angry like what's going
on why is why is she walking this back
she needs to because she didn't know
what she was talking about right so they
get in and they just say tell me where
the line is and i will tow it
look i think part of this is that
you know we think about these members of
congress as like what they're doing in
congress with legislation hearings
briefings investigations so on and so
forth but i think this newer breed of
members of congress and there's people
on the right who are this way as well i
think they see a lot of their
constituency the same way as like an
instagram influencer or like a celebrity
sees their constituency right like as
long as they're making a lot of progress
in terms of the retweets the likes the
shares the subscribers um they're
raising a heck of a lot of money i think
aoc is one of the best fundraisers in
congress because of all our small donor
base and their support i think they see
themselves as achieving some level of
success right and maybe they will even
achieve long-term political success in
their careers by doing it um but it
isn't necessarily the most effective or
the best way to move things in congress
i mean i'll give you an example i think
that you know rashida talib or ilhan
omar
you know they they they get in a lot of
hot water talking about israel in the
middle east
um but what exactly have they
accomplished on those issues like i
can't think of i can't think of them
they aren't any of the authors of any of
the primary legislation on middle east
human rights issues that's betty
mccollum or some other members of
congress when there was a recent
outbreak of fighting in between israel
and gaza it was john ossoff it was a
very kind of loki senator from georgia
who organized the letter calling for a
ceasefire it wasn't an ill tomorrow or
she had to leave
sometimes being the more like outspoken
twitter punchy type person you know
maybe it'll get your applause your
fanbase to make you a little bit of a
celebrity but it isn't necessarily the
way to actually move things in congress
and actually carve out um you know some
progress and i think yeah i mean to be
fair to them i do think that they they
have sometimes unrealistic expectations
put on them i mean they're freshmen
members are calling it so they're like
you know some of them are there have
been there for two terms now um normally
when you're in that position you're not
going to be that effective just because
of how a house operates now the is very
different you can be very effective as a
first-term senator very very impactful
but the house is a little bit different
so some of the expectations are maybe a
little unfair on them but also at the
same time
you know i think of them more as
influencers and i think of them as
lawmakers because that's mostly what
they do i think uh i refer to this as
the aoc phenomenon how is it that she is
such an effective fundraiser
the way i describe it is imagine you
have a hundred cities
and in those cities
47 you know 40 percent are republican
42 are democrat and then you've got a
mix mishmash of libertarian and green
party and
unaffiliated whatever well i think those
numbers are probably unfair because
probably a lot it's like thirds is
probably independent voters but the
point is ignoring that let's say that
out of each city
one percent is
democratic socialist pro aoc
now if you're in that city and you're
trying to fundraise you're not going to
make any money because you're like you
know you got one person who can donate
to you but what if you could tap into
the power of the internet and now you
have every major city across the country
those in each
in each and every city where there's
just one person who believes that you
believe all of a sudden now through the
internet they're connected to you and
funneling money to you and now all of a
sudden aoc is raising money
outside of her district and it's a new
phenomenon they talk about the squad
members getting i think most of their
donations came from outside like the
substantial amount like 97 or whatever
came not from their own districts so
what they're doing is they're they're
taking the fringe of each and every city
they're online speaking up sending money
to aoc aoc is not uh i would say she's
popular in the sense that all of those
people are allowed now but if we were to
if if this was before the internet era
she would not be considered popular i'd
imagine right you have it's interesting
because an equivalent figure if you go
back to like the pre-social media era
would maybe be like dennis kucinich
right like kucinich was probably the
most left-wing member of congress he was
a democrat congressman from ohio he ran
for president a couple times and
basically the bernie platform didn't
really get anywhere
um but it's exactly that like kucinich's
power base was his actual district in
cleveland in ohio or like in cleveland
area at ohio uh he wasn't tapping into a
large sort of internet social media fan
base that maybe represented a small
sliver of america but could give him
tons and tons of money the same way that
i think really starting with ron paul
like ron paul on the right and the
libertarian side you know represented
sort of a minority faction of people but
he was able to mobilize a tremendous
number of internet donors some of which
transferred into volunteers which
increased his profile which actually
gave him a real platform and a voice in
the political debates and actually it
gave him some surprising performance in
those couple of primaries that he ran in
uh i remember the daily show had a
really fun segment about how like he got
maybe second in a state and like the
major media didn't even mention it but
like you know he he obviously was doing
very well punching well above his weight
you know ron paul started that and i
think bernie sanders continued it uh and
now you have people who i think i would
argue are much less impactful than
someone like a bernie sanders which is
the squad um who carved out their social
media niches and yeah i think they
provide them with enough money to
basically fend off any kind of
challenger within their district which
would which would only come from within
their party because they're all very
democratic leaning districts
but that simply isn't the way that you
actually change things in congress the
fulcrum of congress is typically the
swing districts right it's the districts
that a party can't afford to lose
and
the ones that give them the majority and
the control of the committees and the
chairs
but which are always very competitive
because i don't think you can be aoc
talking about prison abolition i mean
that's the real thing she's talked about
and win any swing district anywhere in
america that would be turned into an
advertisement by the the republicans and
you'd be gone and you know the next
cycle but you can sitting in a district
that i don't know if her district is
like d plus 30 or 40 years z plus 30.
yeah it's pretty it's pretty up there uh
you can say basically anything you want
right it'd be very hard for anyone to
defeat her incumbents very rarely lose
any kind of primary challenge and
particularly in that in that kind of
left wing of a district i mean nancy
pelosi said you could take this glass of
water put a d on it and it would win in
aoc's or my district
they know it how how broken is the
system right um you know we we we have
talked with other gop candidates in the
past who are in like deep blue areas
and i'll tell you man the only reason
areas are deep red or deep blue is
because
the the parties don't invest money
they're like what's the point and it's
like well dude if you're not
trying to influence people on your ideas
you're losing and i'll tell you it's
mostly phenomenon of the right they're
they you know we mentioned this before
they don't care about culture
they're sitting there thinking that
appointing federal judges is winning the
culture war and it's like no
because i'll tell you this
you can point out however many judges
you want but if amazon cnn cable tv new
york times all of these things are all
saying x is right and y is wrong the
courts are going to be like i'll just do
what they tell me because you know the
the courts ultimately in the end are
just enforcing popular opinion
we've had we've had a bunch of changes
of precedent and and
over our you know several hundred years
free speech as we know it i think was
only
essentially not literally codified but
precedent was set what like 1968 i think
it was one example of this would be uh
school prayer right like people today a
lot of people you talk to them they're
like well school prayer is not allowed
because that's in the establishment
clause blah blah blah school prayer was
in schools until like the 1950s or
something right the courts were
defending it wasn't a matter of just
like the constitution being rewritten it
was just that the culture's perception
of whether or not it's appropriate
changed right yep and that was much more
important than having a particular judge
on a particular court so as the right
you know these establishment neocon
republican types keep thinking that oh
we're going to just win in the institute
in the in the governmental policies
meaningless
meanwhile the left is controlling all
these institutions taking them over so
you know it is a good point you bring up
that
someone like aoc couldn't win in a swing
district i do think there's something
interesting to be said about the need
for republicans to go into an aoc type
district and actually start advocating
and presenting an alternative well let's
remember that um one of the
he he's obviously in a very different
role these days but one of the icons of
the republican party rudy giuliani
was only that icon because he was able
to win power in new york city yeah now
the republicans do have a nominee in new
york city curtis sleewa who's a former
you know guardian angel
he's actually a very storied figure in
many ways but i you know i haven't
looked it up but i doubt republicans are
investing just about anything in that
race yeah and you know i to be fair to
them i doubt that they would win it no
matter what they invested but it it's a
matter of of long-term investment right
it's a matter of running a series of
competitive candidates until you get
someone like rudy giuliani who's
actually going to win who's going to
pave the way for someone like a michael
bloomberg who's you know semi-republican
um but if you if you don't if you don't
even try yeah obviously you're going to
end up with that result i think this is
what's contributing to the culture war
on the hyper polarization in that
republicans and democrats are like i
have no reason to even talk to the
people in these deep districts and and
now the hyper polarization has gotten so
extreme now they're even more entrenched
in not communicating but if if you if
you just leave
new york city to get further and further
left without even trying then we're
drifting so far apart eventually the
band snaps and then there's just two
different realities i think we're
already starting to see it like portland
announced they will cut off trade and
travel or whatever for texas california
banned state travel to like a handful of
states
you're gonna have this phenomenon that
we talked about before where
truckers aren't gonna go to new york
they're gonna be like i can't go there
because i don't feel like dealing with
the uh you know the the ban on public
accommodations for people who aren't
vaccinated let's say you live in texas
and you're a truck driver and they're
like hey we got a big shipment it's got
to be sent up to new york to be like nah
in texas they don't have the
restrictions in new york they do they're
in the back i don't feel like doing it
which is going to be interesting because
someone in new york is a trucker will be
like oh i can go to texas no problem so
it's creating kind of a one-way track
yeah i mean this is this is the
important thing to understand about
polarization so i actually worked on
polarization professionally from 2018 to
2020 i was i did a fellowship at a at a
center at berkeley called the greater
good science center which works on
psychology science um and so you know i
spent a lot of time talking to
researchers who study it and
practitioners that work on it
here's the thing to understand about
it's not really based on what you
believe right it's not there there is a
a really great political scientist at
the university of maryland liliana mesa
who studied this and what she found was
that people who are most polarized from
each other are people who have very
strong political identities who very
strongly identify with the label like
liberal or conservative in fact they are
even more polarized from each other than
people who disagree more on like an
issue like guns or abortion or something
meaning you can be all the way to the
left but if you don't identify very
strongly as a leftist or a liberal it's
not a core part of your personal
identity
you probably aren't going to be as angry
or resentful or contemptuous of people
who are all the way on the right versus
even if you're somewhat in the middle
but you're like very strongly
identifying yourself as a democrat you
conceive of yourself as that way you can
be much much more polarized against
someone even someone who like agrees
with you on most of the issues but who
has the opposite political identity so i
think it's really about making that
political identity first and foremost
and then just not interacting very much
with people with other identities
because here's the reality i grew up in
the deep south as a very left-leaning
person particularly at that point i was
very left-wing compared to everyone
around me but you know all my friends
were republicans a lot of them hunted
you know you go to waffle house you see
someone with a confederate flag t-shirt
sitting next to someone with an mlk
t-shirt like that was the south growing
up in the 1990s there was so much mixing
and integrating and like old-fashioned
diversity of like you people would look
at you funny if you were like yeah i
don't want to have any friends or
republicans they think you were some
kind of freak or something right
but the facebook vacation of the united
states where everyone has a kind of
curtailed personality and very strong
identity established through exclusively
in some cases politics
has made it much easier for people to
silo each other to segregate from each
other and again to elevate this part of
your identity versus all other parts of
your identity you know it's not your
hobbies it ain't your career it's not
your religion it's not your family life
it's
i in this house we believe xyz you know
you see those signs around northern
virginia you know you see you see i
don't know why they i don't know why
they're putting those signs up do i care
what you believe i don't really i don't
really want to give someone a political
litmus test upon meeting them but that's
what these people really can see with
themselves
it's tribalism i mean and i'll tell you
i think it's it's it's look
republicans i think for the most part
are spineless feckless and aren't
fighting for anything i have very little
to say about
a party that's not doing much they're
not coming out and demanding the
department of gun services and a
repealing of the nfa and a gun in the
hand of every child
you know as much as i would jokingly be
like yeah yeah by all means they're not
doing that
the democrats are absolutely
steamrolling pushing advocating very
very hard for doing these things and
then when i call out the media for lying
what happens i mean look look at matt
tybee i'm sure you get it glenn
greenwald gets it you're all right wing
now you're all right-wing grifters
simply for saying hey media that wasn't
true i think part of it is that when
somebody has a very strong identity they
view it as an identity threat to see
someone disagree with them right and i
think one way to really supposed to be
the other yeah exactly one way to
resolve that threat is to simplify the
world and just say oh that person's in
the other in the other category it's
called um what is it called in group
homogeneity
outgroup homogeneity bias right where
you think that everyone who disagrees
with you basically has one set of narrow
beliefs that all of which you hate and
disagree with right and so yeah it's i
think it would be absurd if someone were
to look at my resume and really honestly
read my writing and think that you know
i'm a staunch right-winger or something
they'll say it if i went down to my uh
state house in virginia or something and
told them what i believe on criminal
justice they'd probably think i was like
a lunatic communist or something like
you know but what if i go on twitter and
i say something that like 60 of
americans agree with you know people
will reply saying i'm rudy giuliani or
i'm a fascist blah blah and it's just
like what are you talking about it's
like it's an it's an alternate reality
right my favorite is uh the satanic
temple they're suing over the abortion
bill in texas
and so i just sweet as like i want okay
so one of the tenants of the satanic
temple is that your body is inviable it
is yours and no one can you know mess
with it or whatever and i'm like
all right like what's your thoughts on
the new york vaccine mandate because i
agree with you completely and i'm
pro-choice i've always been pro-choice i
have wonderful arguments with pro-lifers
and there's a sort of a libertarian
impasse we come to and uh we go into
great detail explaining this 50 billion
times i don't know if i can do it again
but when i post something like you know
my body my choice i get these these
tribal leftists on twitter who will say
yeah but when it come to texas you
prolifers and i'm like i'm not pro-life
and they're like
well you're grifting them and then i'm
like i'm grifting to whom the left who
is in favor of the vax mandates by me
complaining about them or the right
who's pro-life and me saying i'm
pro-choice which who am i gifting to you
know it's really funny i think the
people who tell you that they always
assume that you are captive to somebody
else they never assumed that like let's
say if someone who's very right-wing
decide to have a conversation with you
that maybe you might convince them right
like it where it actually does work both
ways but they assume it only goes one
way exactly so something i've often said
is politics flows in one direction if
there is a photo of
me
with a far left antifa guy they'll
accuse the entity of a guy of being
right wing
because it it but like me like i'm i'm
fairly independent centrist moderate
with some left-leaning policy some
right-leaning policies but if i'm
sitting next to someone on the right
they'll say ah that proves that tim's
far right if i stand with someone left
like whoa i didn't realize that antifa
guy was actually far right because it
only can go in one direction there's no
circumstance in which you take a
right-wing individual have him hang out
and crack beers with leftists and they
claim the right-wing right-winger is a
left-winger which is wild because i
think that you know a lot of the recent
american history shows that
you know it's called contact hypo
intergroup contact or contact hypothesis
which is basically when people hang out
with each other you break down barriers
between each other so this is for the
most part been a huge win for the left
over the past 50 or 60 years of american
history right there's been much less
racial prejudice much less religious and
gender prejudice as a result of people
basically just mixing it up with each
other like that was you can talk about
all different ways techniques strategies
to make this happen but ultimately
there's people mixing up with each other
it was integrating right people just
getting to know each other being friends
has made america one of the most
tolerant places like on planet earth and
like in human history generally it's
worked out very well for left-wing goals
i would say absolutely i agree um let's
go to super chats if you haven't already
smash the like button subscribe to
subscribe to the channel share the show
and become a member at timcast.com
because we're gonna have a members-only
segment coming up after the show you'll
you'll not want to miss them they're
always so much fun because you swear a
whole lot
but uh you know what i'm going to do
i saw a super chat which is more recent
usually i go back to the beginning but
we're going to read this one just
because there's there's two points to be
said
jj says tim your argument against
ivermectin because horses are large
shows how little you have actually
researched the subject please do some
journalism and actually research the
subject jj you saying this shows how
little you've actually watched my
commentary on ivermectin and other
medicine because i've done a tremendous
amount of research in fact i would argue
more than many commentators and my
argument is not that there's something
wrong with it because horses are large
clearly you have not heard the plethora
of videos i've made about this
what i've been saying is
first
when it comes to the first thing i'll
say is here's the challenge in doing
these shows
if i break down if i do a 15 minute
segment explaining my entire thought
process so you can understand the
subject matter people complain tim you
talk about that too much we get it the
issue is if i don't i get super chats
like this where they're like you have no
idea what you're talking about so i can
choose to do a 20 minute explainer on
the morals and ethics of a particular
issue in the news behind it or i can
just be like here's a quick summary
moving on but then people complain
because they don't actually watch my
videos they hear one thing so let me
just break this down really really
quickly for you guys
people are ingesting full tubes of horse
paste not in mass numbers not shutting
down hospitals and there have been calls
to poison center places about this don't
do that don't take the horse paste and
i'll tell you why it's not because
horses are large it's because humans
have different quality product grading
than animals do and there's also issues
like horses can tolerate certain
substances humans can't or dogs can't
tolerate certain substances humans can i
can't give you a full list of all of the
chemicals and break down the formulation
for you that's why it's important you go
to a doctor ask them and make sure that
if you are prescribed any medication you
go to a you go to a pharmacist to get
that actual medication but i'll i'll
tell you it's it's it's this simple the
fda says the formulation for animal
grade ivermectin contains things that
have not been graded for humans a horse
liver may be able to process certain
things that you can't did you know that
cats can drink salt water you can't you
will lose your mind dehydrate yourself
and die you wouldn't then be like well
if the cat can drink it i can drink it
even if it's in small amounts no it's
not true you're totally different when
the fda approves something they'll be
like okay it can't have these things in
it because humans don't react with it
properly and they'll get sick no but
horses
that won't bother them at all because
they have a different digestive tract
and different liver and cows have
multiple stomachs that's the issue
that's why don't eat horse paste in any
amount and go to a doctor and find one
who's knowledgeable about all this stuff
and knows more than i do and and putting
it simply there are studies that are
conflicted on ivermectin some say it's
good some say it's not there's data from
countries saying it's good there's some
other information saying it's it's it
studies that they're like no it's
actually inconclusive and these studies
are wrong or it's a spurious correlation
i can't tell you what is true because
there's no
definitive statement there's competing
narratives in a culture war so the only
thing i can say is you make the decision
that's right for you
talk to someone you trust professionals
when it comes to medical decisions and
that's the breakdown of that tweet that
being said let's go back to the
beginning and read some of these super
chats
all right let's see
billy stamatello says biden got heckled
on his hurricane ida tour lol you'd love
to see it shout out to the 201 sending
love to the tri-state and the rest of
the country yay thanks for the super
chat
oh this is great chameleon dx says tim
big fan of yours but as someone who
makes wine professionally watching your
wine tasting over the weekend hurt my
soul good
that was the intention good
so we we uh we went for a labor day
weekend we went to central west virginia
look at these ghost towns it was awesome
and we got these local berry wines so
cool like blackberry raspberry blueberry
and i have no idea what i'm doing so i
just pretended to know what i was doing
and then we like mixed all the wines
together to make wine punch i'm sure
that was the most offensive thing we
could have done gosh what's highly
offensive
drink wine
i knew we would trigger some uh wine
professionals how was the punch
it tasted good i don't know
listen okay
when you're when you're in
the middle of uh
west virginia
you're you're you're you're duct tape
you know it's it's it's we're not we're
not yeah moonshine we're not talking
about some fancy winery of people
wearing fancy suits and tuxedos sipping
with their pinkies out we're talking
about taking a barrel and filling it
with whatever you got fermenting it and
drinking what you got
not really i mean it was actually really
good wine you know but you know i mix
them together because we do what we want
all right let's see what else we got
3d pyromaniac says
to be united by hatred is a fragile
alliance at best darth traya funny how a
game about space wizards has a better
understanding of philosophy than the
modern left
yeah
yeah
pedro henrique says have you guys seen
jason miller get her ceo as a rest of
the day in brazil for our independence
bolsonaro is going through the same
pressure trump did he was detained for
questioning did you guys see this no
this is brutal
did you hear about it yeah i heard about
it i think glenn was tweeting about it
too the craziest thing about it is uh
jason miller former senior adviser to
trump
he's about to leave he's getting on his
plane or he was about to get on his
plane they detained him and questioned
him for three hours
and your uh go-to figures on twitter
were cheering for it and i'm like yo are
we really at the point
where one politic like people citizens
of this country are cheering for a
foreign government detaining an american
citizen who was leaving
that to me is funny because i think that
a lot of this started with like
trump rallies and like lock her up and
now i feel like locker up is like a
universal thing like there are always
democrats hoping that a range of
republicans like expelled from congress
and or arrested
which is a weird thing in a pluralistic
democratic society for people to be to
be asking for or wanting i mean
obviously there are public officials who
actually commit crimes and like it
happens every now and then but like this
is all politically motivated it's like
pretty obvious right so i think it does
not bode well for us we had john podesta
you know according to boston globe was
arguing for the west coast to secede
from the union in the event of a trump
victory you've got states saying we
can't travel to these states anymore
you've got conflicting policies some
states you know uh oregon sued the
federal government over when trump was
trying to stop the riots
like the fracturing in this country is
just getting absolutely worse and i'll
tell you if there was a collapse
happening
you wouldn't see it because you're in it
you know slow motion breakdown you're
standing in the middle of the forest
surrounded by trees and you're like what
forest where all i see is trees
and that's and that's the issue right
now but i tell you
if
i'm right and and i think we have
absolutely been on this trajectory
towards collapse or civil conflict or
something in 50 to 100 years they'll be
like oh this whole period was the
breakdown of the american empire and all
that stuff
all right this sounds very weird so i'm
gonna read it oh good josh oh my gosh
says hey ian what if parallel universes
are a mechanism for a higher dimensional
womb using the accumulative experiences
of every sentient living creature in
every universe to make a baby that knows
everything when born mic drop
yeah i think we're in a black hole and
that your thoughts are
causing matter to come in from the
outside of the black hole so it looks
like it's expanding but matter is
actually just coming in from the outside
i think you beat him
might be on something josh
yeah
all right cat purple says journalism
used to be a blue collar job then the
elites took it over and then it became a
leap propaganda
simple leap propaganda
was it ever a blue collar yeah i think
tybee actually writes about this which
is that back in the day it was sort of
just like something if you were just
kind of like
you know you you were kind of like
second or third tier your school or
college and you just you needed a job
and because there were so many local
newspapers back then right before there
was so much consolidation
um so a lot of people who entered
journalism i think were kind of people
who were not at the top of their
business business or law school or they
weren't cut out for medicine so on and
so forth it wasn't really seen as an
elite trade until very recently or
something that
was all that prestigious i guess um at
least when you're talking about your
run-of-the-mill journalists so i think
there's a lot of truth to that although
i don't know exactly
like i don't have a figure or something
what the average journalist was like 50
years ago versus now but yeah it
definitely the nature and prestige of
the trade has changed a lot
well i have seen anchorman
and if it's anything like that it was
bad
yeah it's just like that i'm sure
quedo osta says tim do you think fathers
have any rights over unborn children
like if you got your girlfriend pregnant
like if you got your girlfriend pregnant
didn't tell you and got an abortion
would you be upset if society make men
responsible for impregnation it would
only be fair they get some rights it's
very interesting and i think the answer
is yes i don't think it's equal i will
also add that
you know we were talking on the show
last week and people were saying that
the texas abortion law has exemptions
for rape and incest it doesn't
yeah it doesn't and i read a couple
different articles saying there is no
exception in that case that law is a bad
bad bad bad law
um it is tough though it is it is still
very difficult uh
to to
parse this out morally though there is a
medical exemption but no exemption for
rape and that tends to be the the main
focal point of the argument i'm seeing
for money on the left that are
advocating for the right at any point to
abortion specifically rape and i'm like
yeah the state's saying that somebody
was forced by someone else and then that
person is is the one who took the action
to imprint the woman the woman didn't
choose to do that then the argument from
people in the chat was that
you know if the woman makes a choice she
has a responsibility to the life inside
of her but what if she didn't make that
choice texas should have an exemption in
that regard it's not easy this is
probably one of the most morally
ethically uh difficult questions of our
of our of our lives like be honest
all right let's see we got here
delta 34 says hey tim and cass i worked
a few years on a project to find a
universal formula for morality i have it
almost fully animated and narrated what
does an enlightenment defender got to do
to come on and share it um are you
checking the uh spin the ufo yeah stuff
yeah yeah spin the ufo gmail.com yeah
you're welcome to resend it it might
have slipped through the cracks but i do
check yep there you go
matthew hunter says the horse-paced
tubes are meant to be dosed by weight
and it's the same dose per pound for
humans as for horses don't take 1250
pounds worth of ibm unless you weigh
that much regardless simple no not
simple as i've explained
look
some people are arguing but i think the
issue is
are you really going to trust
that they're going to keep a product
safe when the liability is substantially
lower there's another issue with with
with horse medication versus human
medication
it may be ivermectin as the active
ingredient it doesn't mean the inactive
ingredients are the same i think the
ivermectin paste is like 90 what is it
98
percent
not ivermectin there's other active
ingredients in it sounds right if a
human being ingests something and dies
the liability for the company could be
in the tens of millions
if a horse ingests something and dies
depending on the horse the liability
could be in the tens of thousands so
i'll just put it this way
just talk to a doctor man
don't go to a tractor supply because you
it's just
i hear these stories about you know
we've heard a lot of stories about
people going on amazon and going on
these other websites and buying you know
prescription drugs but off prescription
by going other companies countries and
stuff like that i think that's all bad
too i think you know but you know what
look i'll tell you this
my opinion my choice for my life your
opinion your choice for your life
all right let's see we got
michael martin says fauci and rand paul
more proof that more proof that the
difference between conspiracy theories
and the truth is about 60 to 90 days
thank you for being my nightly news hey
thanks for for watching we try our best
what is
natalie kucia says
hey tim and crew just wanted to hear you
say rachel mad cow out loud
please feel free to go around the table
and have everyone say it well i'll read
it but uh people don't have it i love it
no no
all right let's see
daniel bundrick says tim please issue a
correction ibuprofen is toxic to dogs i
will have your reference here denier e
iberoprofen toxicism dogs cats and
ferrets vet med um
we just google search i have a profit
for dogs and there's like dog branded
ibuprofen so i don't know
whatever uh perhaps you can't give too
much of it to them but the joke i was
making is that
they they prescribe the same antibiotics
and the same like painkillers to pets
and so what are we gonna do we're gonna
go around being like joe biden was seen
ingesting dog medicine today at the
white house and it's like he's holding a
bottle of aspirin it's like dude it's
aspirin it's it's it's for what it's for
you know what i mean
all right let's see where we're at
ethan davis tim i think i might have an
answer
or part of the answer to your question
about what happened to people the rage
and i think it stems back to the birth
of the internet and the death of
innocence
so one of the things we've pointed out
frequently is how people have become
extremely angry
you know people i've known my whole life
all of a sudden are just
messaging me saying extremely angry vile
things not like and i'm just like yo why
are you so mad like there are people
i've known for decades were friends on
facebook and also messaging me with all
caps being like i'm sick of this you're
out of the facts and i'm like why are
you yelling at me
and they're just like they have no real
answer it's like where did this anger
and rage come from that people are just
so angry all the time now yeah i mean i
think part of that is they've
externalized their mental state or their
problems right i mean maybe something is
is happening in their personal lives or
they have some lack of personal
fulfillment and they've they've taken
that and turned it into a political
problem right if this wasn't happening
in the world it wasn't happening to
society and politics i'd be happier
right and that's when they they
personalize those problems i i do marvel
at like you know i know people who are
like war refugees who came to the united
states who were very chill and relaxed
and very happy about living here and
then i know people who grew up here
upper middle class who seem like you
know enraged and upset all the time it's
just like it doesn't really make a whole
lot of sense if you think about their
external life circumstances right but it
makes a lot of sense if you think about
this as a failure for them to like
establish like an internal locus of
control and actually recognize their
personal problems as personal problems
and like it doesn't mean you shouldn't
care about the world or engage with it
but like if you find yourself being
personally enraged and being anti-social
towards your friends or your colleagues
then you know there is something that
you need to work on personally before
you fix the rest of the world so yeah
you know i think there's a couple things
at play people have no purpose in their
lives uh we went when we were in west
virginia west virginia
uh i they have these things called hot
spots they're basically just like
miniature casinos
so we were bored it's late and i'm like
i don't want to sit in as you know
sunday night or whatever on labor day
let's go to let's go to these little hot
spots we drove like 10 miles we go to
this place and it's a little hole in the
wall lounge they've got i think seven
slot machines and each machine has like
a different you can play games they're
all full they were like two machines
open so we played i ended up winning a
ton of money it was awesome i turned 60
bucks into 400. but the point is
people who are there
just gambling
you know that's kind of sad like that's
your that's that's what that's that and
they're all over the place after we left
that hot spot we went to another one
same thing you know seven or eight slot
machines people sitting around gambling
and i'm just like
they have no purpose
there's nothing to do their their work
is done they're sitting at home they're
bored they want to go out so they just
go to the slot machine and start you
know pulling the lever
and i think
that occupies them that keeps them
relatively sane it's like i'm gonna go
do my thing my routine but there's a lot
of people in cities who don't have that
so now they're home from work they have
their bills paid they they have no
purpose so they find black lives matter
they find anti-fun they get angry
the the the hole in their hearts that
they feel is externalized and then you
add covet on top of that people are
locked in their apartments
and now what do they say it's the it's
the unvaccinated fault it's your fault
it's trump's fault it's not my fault
it's your fault
there was a there's a documentary
filmmaker dia khan and she's made
documentaries about both white
nationalists and islamists and she got
to know them very well actually and i
think she was on the same harris show or
something and she actually explained
some of her like thoughts on making the
documentaries and she's i think she
noticed that there were a lot of
similarities between the two sides a lot
of people would think no those people
are diametrically opposed or different
politically religiously so on and so
forth um but she basically found that
they were young alienated people who
needed some purpose in their lives and
this is what filled it many people could
have easily become like guitar players
or bullying enthusiasts or you know any
any number of things they could have
filled the hole with something healthier
but this just happens to be the door
they picked and it led them to a very
unhealthy place and i think that
they sincerely believed
that if they had won whatever political
struggle they were involved in their
sectarian struggle that they would be
happier people uh but it was the same it
was the same mistake both sides were
making in this equation from the
extremists that she had covered and of
course most people were talking about in
these cases they're not actual
extremists and they're not violent or
breaking the law or anything but
it's a miniature version of the same
problem right
i think that's probably where a lot of
it comes from because under trump things
are pretty good
maybe one of the components is that with
2019 being so good you know i i heard
from so many people about how they made
so much money and then 2020 was just so
awful and you know what
maybe maybe people starting to realize
that this year with everything that's
getting bad a lot of the anger is coming
from their decision to vote for joe
biden i mean look at sam harris saying
he's eating his words
so they go through this very you know
they go through 2020 they blame trump
for everything it's your fault
everything was so good it's your fault
now it's 2021
and biden's in charge and it's still bad
and now there may be a lot of them are
maybe having this cognitive dissonance
of maybe
it was it was the pandemic and maybe
voting for biden is not going to change
anything and they're just there's no way
to solve it so they blame everyone else
all right jda says the journalistic
exodus to sub stack is not the only one
in the past few months the top writers
for dc and marvel have moved to sub
stack also
what remains at dc marvel is the worst
of the woke wow wow you know we saw
shang qi
yeah oh how was it
uh
i liked it i didn't like it i thought it
was okay it was okay that was okay give
it a c i i think that um i could have
fixed it they picked a lot of good
chinese or hong kong scene actors uh to
be part of it who really kind of stole
the show even though they were side
characters
and that was i think that was a pretty
good decision on their part to pick
those people i think the challenge was
that they were trying to make
they should have gone all in on on china
in my opinion
instead they tried break adding some
like american stuff to it to make it
so like americans could
relate to it i guess nah it should have
been
it should have just been in china right
so so i don't i'm not going to spoil
anything but shang chi
is from china but he
lives in america and then goes to china
and i'm just like that just made the
whole thing confusing yeah
well what's interesting is like the
larger context of it is disney's trying
to expand heavily in chinese market as
our
much as much of hollywood so i think the
more they can set in china the easier it
will be for them because i think a lot
of the chinese audience isn't as
interested in some of the american stuff
um so i think they were trying to split
the difference and get both audiences
involved and you know
to be fair i wasn't right so like look
we i we've got a bunch of marvel movies
that are really really good
if you're gonna make a marvel movie
about the mandarin with his ten rings
and he's
chinese and he has chinese children you
don't need to put him in san francisco
for 10 minutes like it just made the
story not make sense and there were a
bunch of things they could have done i
already figured how to fix the entire
movie because i did it with dr strange
the what-if episode but i've i i'm like
man i wish there were so many missed
beats but but it was good it was it was
um
i would say i give it a a grade c
meaning
uh i enjoyed going out and watching it
um had fun you know hanging out in the
theater it was enjoyable and uh
what was what's the actor's name simu
sema i don't know i don't know he was
really good he was really really good
and the guy who plays that i thought
they both did really really great i
think everybody did a great job um but
i'll tell you this i always i can always
tell you
my ultimate rating is not a thumb up or
thumbs down it's what i watch the movie
again
and i would say for the movie doctor
strange from 2016
i watched that movie on loop i love that
movie so much shang qi
you know honestly i i at first i always
said no i'd watch it again i wouldn't go
to the theaters when it comes out i'll
probably put it on and watch it again
but not particularly strong you know so
it's like yeah enjoyed it you know i
think the ending was fun but uh they
could have done a way better job i think
a lot of it was it wasn't explained as
as like what was happening wasn't
explained well enough yeah they didn't
give the main character as much
characterization in this one for sure
yeah
it was it really felt like it was a
bunch of scenes that were edited
together
that was my issue with it and i'm like
they needed only a little bit to make it
like totally epic
and
oh man i don't want to spoil anything so
i won't say much but they needed only a
few sentences and a few tweaks in like
one or two places and it would have been
like
one of the greatest films ever
so that says a lot it was it was it was
i liked it it was good but you know i'm
not going to give it an a
unfortunately but i was excited for it
it's good to see
all right let's see what we got here
insert name here says tim when are you
going to have colleen noir or another
prominent to a voice on also i know it's
not your focus but you rarely talk about
anti-2a stuff
um we talk about gun control
periodically we had the the the fella
from phoenix ammunition on recoil uh
we've had the guys from recoil yeah or
the guy from recoil forest uh
we are
staunchly pro-2a
to an extreme degree when when uh
we had uh colonel allen west here and he
was saying that like if you commit a
felony you lose your right to have a gun
and i was like i disagree i think once
you get out of prison your gun back and
he was like i don't know about that
violent criminals and i'm like yep i
think so i think if you get out of
prison you get your gun you get your
vote you get everything back that's how
it works you outflanked the texas
republican
well people were like tim rights can be
taken from you through due process and
i'm like a life sentence never owning a
firearm to defend yourself
after you got out of prison i think it's
a little much now like
okay for sure like you're a murderer or
something with 25 to life and after 30
years they let you out
we can have a discussion about some kind
of like
extended due process of restrictions
i still lean towards yeah get out of
prison you get your vote you get your
gun back
that's just me
all right let's see
delhiopoulos says the argument
governments shouldn't legislate morality
doesn't hold water when it's obvious
that the left has no problem legislating
immorality
that's one of the big challenges i
suppose is that when it comes to any
kind of you know culture war issue
you have people who are like i'm gonna
play by the rules be nice and tell the
truth and the other side saying we're
gonna lie cheat and steal and who's
likely to win in that conflict you know
if you're playing a game against
somebody and they're willing to lie
cheat and steal you're at a serious
disadvantage
this stuff
all right let's see
wicked karma 1776 says i'm completely
wrong about ivermectin saying look at
ivermectin metastudy peer-reviewed 63
studies 21 000 patients
so so i did and we talked to dr chris
martinson about that and the issue was
there's a bunch of reports from like
universities and medical journals saying
that you know those a lot of those
studies were done wrong the methodology
was bad and so all i'm saying is this
i don't i'm not going to trust someone
simply because someone else says like i
know i know person a is lying it doesn't
mean person b is telling the truth it's
so so my ultimate position is
it's a it's the media is lying about it
across the board with the horse-paced
thing the media is lying about you know
joe rogan and they're putting out these
headlines to manipulate you
i can't tell you about efficacy because
there's conflicting studies even with
this one big you know meta-analysis
there's there's a bunch of uh
researchers saying that's not not
correct so
i'm gonna i'm gonna leave it to you guys
to go talk to a doctor make sure there's
someone you trust and look man there are
people in the culture war i don't care
which side they're on who are going to
believe things and tell you things and
you're going to navigate this world but
ultimately
i i try to be careful of people who are
trying to win some kind of you know
cultural issue when it comes to my
personal health decisions by all means i
think the right tends to be more more
publishing the truth in media not always
and the left tends to be publishing lies
and manipulations the establishment left
that doesn't mean i'm going to blindly
trust anybody and if i don't have
definitive data in front of me even if i
want to believe something i'm not going
to make a move on it sorry it's uh it's
up to you to talk to somebody who's got
the expertise and everything and by all
means tell me i'm wrong that's fine tell
me you trust brett weinstein because
he's the evolutionary biologist way more
credentialed than i am my position is my
position because i'm not in a position
to have any equities on this stuff
it's the best i can do my friends
oh okay so here we go so i've got some
pushback on the uh abortion thing
zachariah kitzman says tim you're wrong
about the abortion law not having
exemptions it's already written into
texas law the heartbeat bills uh in
addition to the newly standing law
i'll have to do a deep dive on this one
because there's been a i think the
governor was asked about this
and this week or this past week and he
said something like well you have six
weeks so six weeks
takes a count you know that the time
someone would need in that emergency
situation to seek it but i don't think
it has an explicit exemption right and
then he also didn't say something like
well we're going to hunt down all the
rapists to stop this yeah that was also
kind of a weird something like it takes
you i don't see how that was i really
really know the issue but yeah yeah yeah
so um
you know but uh i'll i'll do a deep dive
to make sure but i i i saw that because
we had said on the show we had people on
the show saying there is an exception
for this it's cleverly crafted i was
like oh okay all right well that makes
sense
and then um
i saw some advocacy groups saying
there's there's no exemption for for
rape or incest and so i said okay i
better fact check this one i pulled up a
handful of articles saying there is no
exception and i was like oh okay well i
guess i was wrong about that but i could
be wrong about being wrong about that so
i'll just actually dig into the law and
and pull it up as i should have done in
the first place well there you go
all right let's see oh someone mentions
that there is uh the day after pill that
victims can take oh yeah
uh someone is asking me for joe rogan's
phone number this is the weirdest thing
when people like i get we get a lot of
people who come through here email and
they'll be like yeah yeah oh and by the
way can you uh call joe for me and i'm
like no i can't what are you that's
that's
bro
you know a funny story though once i was
at a boost mobile this is like 15 years
ago oh man this is like 16 years no it's
like 15 years ago and uh the guy who
worked there had robin williams phone
number
because i guess he looked it up because
they had the computers
and he i heard him talking to his
co-worker about how he had it and i was
like
bs you don't have his phone number he's
like yeah dude i was like prove it he's
like i'm not gonna give you his phone
number and i was like you don't got it
and then he holds it up for about a
second and then pulls it away and then i
was just like 867 5309 and he was like
oh dude dude please please please like
he didn't realize i would just
photographic memory and know the number
but that was funny i don't know if it
was actually his number though there's
probably some guy bsing at the shop
but i don't know why i told that story
all right let's see
sunny james says with all these
mainstream media resignations are they
taking early retirement to save face
as the left gets more centralized the
joy behar type or matteo type operations
get too expensive and less needed how
many people you need to say the same
thing
i mean yeah well rachel maddow is giving
like 30 million for like a network now
or something
yeah she's kind of grandfathered in
though i think she's been at this for a
while and
it's kind of giving her a level of
security because they they have an
audience who wants that every night but
it's true that the
the younger cohorts millennials and
zoomers are probably not going to want
or need that format oh yeah it's uh
so people like to point out that the key
demo ratings are abysmal for cnn cnn and
msnbc but it's true our ratings are
higher
than in the key demo
than cnn cnn msnbc hl1 whatever
but their total viewership because they
have people who are over 55
is like brings them up to the hundreds
of thousands close to a million
that being said on youtube we can brag
all day and night but there's probably a
thousand channels that are in the same
category of beating rachel maddow's
ratings so it's not to say that we're
doing that well we're like probably i
mean actually the the tim castaire is
apparently a top itunes podcast now
consistently which is great news uh
when i was doing tim pool daily show
every single day i reached like number
17 like total podcasts and then when i
stop doing weekends it just knocks you
off because that's how it works or
whatever but you know whatever it is
what it is we we we can brag about how
they're doing really bad but the reality
is they're still doing really really
well on youtube so we got to be we got
to recognize that for what that means
for the future but that being said my
friends thank you all so much for
hanging out go to timcast.com become a
member we're going to have a
members-only segment coming up where we
talk about the aclu flip-flopping and
the corruption of mainstream
institutions and how it took place why
it took place so you'll definitely want
to see that smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends leave us a good review
you can follow us at tim castle or el
you can follow me personally at tim cast
zed you wanna shout anything out
uh just basically uh yeah check out our
sub stack at inquiremore.com uh for six
dollars a month we hope to give you guys
a lot of a lot of good content a lot of
good original reporting and a news
analysis that you won't get elsewhere so
where can people follow you on twitter
yeah so my twitter is just my first name
and last name so z-a-i-d j-i-l-a-n-i so
thanks man um you can follow me ian
crossland.net hit me up on social medias
at ian crossland good to see him
and it occurred to me that you guys
might not know what email tim's
referring to and this is just spin the
ufo gmail.com so if you want to send
something my direction i will read it i
probably won't respond to it because i
do get a lot a lot of email in general
anyway um but i am always sifting
through it and you guys are welcome to
follow me on twitter at sourpatchlids we
will see all of you at timcast.com the
member segment goes up usually around 11
or so p.m so check it out and we'll see
you all there
you